right good evening ladies and gentlemen
welcome to tonight's plan in East
Committee well I've got a packed program
of applications which will be discussing
the planning merits of all the
applications on the agenda before we
start could be please ensure our mobile
phones are either on silent or switched
off and I'll just do my at the same time
because there's nothing worse than being
interrupted by The Great Escape
or my car feels to bolívar's just when
you're middle of mid-flow and could you
also ensure that when a speaker is
speaking you do not interrupt that
speaker it might be very tempting to
interrupt that speaker but please could
you not interrupt thank you I just like
to introduce the top table on my right
I'm bangs from committee services major
national legal services in count 8 team
leader east team in my role as an
impartial advisor to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
as such I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct of the Royal Town
Planning Institute committee members are
not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by overall advice
Thank You Colin planner Louise Casey
planner Joseph Brooke planner thank you
everybody
sends a bit like University Challenge
isn't it yeah yeah my santosh reading
planning hi yeah on the we move on to
the first item on the agenda which is
apologies for absence children have
apologies from councillor Kendall thank
you disclosure of interest serve members
any disclosures cuts the fielding oh we
got those tonight
in my ward which is 1801 8 John Fierro
you just can speak a bit closer place 18
stroke zero one eight six zero full
lower grounds from Main Street middle
Thai sir your your ward member and
you'll be stepping down from that one I
am indeed sir
thank you catch the saint yes two or
three I was approached the other day by
the app by two applicants on tonight's
agenda
the first one was the land of ox Hill
bridle road pillows in her sea and I
pointed out to the later it wasn't in my
ward therefore I didn't need to be
approached but I still wouldn't had a
peep unaccompanied before penny and
looks at me totally disgusted and then
there is the first field application in
my ward where I did have a conversation
with the applicant at the weekend and
will you be stepping down for that one I
will be stepping down for that thank you
okay slow done or I'd never looked
disgusted at councillor st. I just like
that noted so I will be stepping down
for the first one of one eight four
slash zero one eight nine six four slash
ful cuz I'll be speaking as ward member
thank you catch the parry good evening
chairman I wish to disclose interest in
item six and seven on the agenda which
reflect the king's head applications
I'll be stepping down as I should be
speaking Thank You penny on ticket thank
you
brilliant item number three the minutes
the meeting held on the 3rd of October
are you happy that I sign those
good thank you so we now move on to item
number four which is application 18 /
zero one eight nine six ful lund off ox
Hill bridle road bulletin her C and
Allison Thank You mr. chairman
the application site is situated in the
open countryside to the south of peloton
Hosey as shown by the black dot the
application involves the change of use
of approximately four and a half
hectares of land from agricultural to
equestrian erection of two stable
buildings to provide livery for eight
horses with ancillary storage and tack
room a managed lighting new vehicle and
pedestrian access a horse walker and
associated hard standing and a car park
the application site fronts on to a
class II Road ox Hill bridle road and
there is a public footpath that runs
outside around the outside to the south
of the site after the application site
Oxford bridle road turns into a bridle
road a bridle way and continues to one
further farm there is a ditch running
along the line of the road from north to
south which is the subject at times of
surface water flooding here is an aerial
view showing the location of the
application site within the yellow line
there are two barns opposite the
northern corner this is the plan showing
the proposed layout involving the change
of use of land from a question to
agricultural to equestrian erection of
two stable blocks here and here
with ancillary storage and tack rooms
within the buildings a new vehicle and
pedestrian access a horse walker and
associated hard standing in car parking
area here this slide shows the
elevations for the larger stable
building approximately fourteen by
twelve meters four meters to the ridge
it would provide stabling for six horses
this slide shows plans and elevations
for the smaller stables building
approximately twelve and a half by 3.6
meters 3 meters to the ridge it would
provide stabling for two horses this
slide shows a typical view along Axio
bridle road with the application site on
the left of the picture this slide shows
the view along the footpath along the
western boundary of the site
and this is the point to where a new
access will be made through the hedge
row on Axio bridle road and this slide
shows the barn opposite the application
site there are two updates mr. chairman
as detailed on the update sheet and the
recommendation is to approve these
application this application for the
reason detailed in the report subjects
the updates thank you that's pretty
clear and krav our first speaker please
which is catch the Shaun case
hello case the case yes please yeah and
if you push the button in the middle and
the red light should come on I got three
minutes would you like a warning shot
with about 30 seconds to go yes please
warning about warning shots and doesn't
sound very good thank you hello I'm
Shaun case of her Zee Parish Council
presenting the council's unanimous views
please note that 22 parishioners
objected and another three verbally
commented councillors that they didn't
write in because they thought that our
objections speak for them that's 40% of
all our householders objecting we're
concerned that as Stratford District
Council holds a charge on this land the
granting of planning permission poses a
direct conflict of interest we are
worried that granting change of use here
on part of Marsden Hill eco site would
set precedent for building on other
local fields the increase in large
vehicle traffic from 8 owners checking
horses daily would adversely affect our
current use of this very quiet single
track with no passing places local
joggers walkers riders and cyclists
including young children all value the
peace and safety of a recreational
rarely-used know through wrote it has
three blind bends historically low level
of maintenance from highways no passing
places
and all bar one householder will endure
the extra traffic generated by this
business 200 yards before the proposed
new entrance through the hedgerow the
road deteriorates to an unmade track
passing over the fragile culvert shown
in photo 1 we are particularly worried
by the weight of construction traffic
required to prepare the site and produce
the men arch as shown by the product
information cited in the application we
are disappointed by highways opinion
that this track can manage such a
traffic heavy business when call
strategy 26 section 7.2 mitigation point
2 requires you to ensure that the scale
of traffic generated by the proposal is
appropriate for the function and
standard of the roads serving the area
see photo - a rare lorry close to the
proposed access we believe that oxalá
Riedel Road is not appropriate for this
business traffic power generators are
inappropriate for this rural setting the
proposed generator operates 59 decibels
described as moderate stroke a noisy
home on the hardware info decibel chart
this would be placed in a currently
silent field the applicant suggests that
floodlights won't affect nearby houses
yet estimates that in winter owners
checking on horses would need lighting
for at least two hours each evening
examples of in inaccuracies in in this
application include page 11 of the
updated declarations certificate B
applicant take no to the question can
the site be seen from a public road
footpath for other public land the
drainage ditch referred to as a seasonal
stream this land floods as seen in photo
3 taken from the culvert the other route
to this site is through a Ford so
raising questions about how staff and
owners would access horses in such
weather thank you that was perfect thank
you for the answer fielding and cancel
apparent at the end of this read there
is a farm and as it's an arable air
there must be some fairly hefty tractors
and trailers that use that road I don't
know what acreage the farm is but I
would have thought that that causes
quite a lot of problems with young
people and people on bicycles is that a
problem that that you are aware of sorry
I should ask the question No the pot the
point we're trying to make is that
there's one small holding at the end of
this Lane and the photo of the lorry was
a very rare event so we we've managed to
photograph it to point out how narrow
this truck is building a safari Thank
You chair good evening thank you in
light of the objection or number of
letters objecting to this particular
application in your parish can you just
advise what sort of consultation the
applicant has undertaken with the Parish
Council absolutely none we've heard
nothing from the applicant any further
questions Thank You counsel case you're
free to go thank you
our second speaker and I believe it is
Ross Williams good evening now I've got
some photographs so they won't say next
when I'm ready I'm Ross Williams you've
got three minutes I'm Ross Williams
speaking on behalf of a large number of
local residents I've lived next door to
the land for 36 years this location on
an unmade Road is absolutely not like
many other livery yards in the county
nobody in their right mind would attempt
to change the use of these fields to a
commercial business slide 1 thank you
difficult and costly at best disastrous
environmentally generating significant
intensification of traffic 365 days per
year 7 a.m. to 9 p.m. from 8 clients on
full livery who will come and go to
train on the manoj practice exercise
hunt perhaps three times a week
hack take their horses to shows and
events Plus staff staff transport horse
boxes farriers vets
HGV and LGV deliveries the land is
hugely pronounced rich in furrow now
largely covered by scrub with drainage
ponds and a stream to one side next
slide please
it's infested by doc and rag word the
poisonous plant that kills forces but
the applicants not going to spray highly
impractical the seed will continue to
germinate for years next slide there are
bats deer badgers black newts they might
be possibly crested newts I don't know
in the ponds next slide barn owls
regularly caught over the long grass
their preferred hunting habitat there
are many many wildflowers vital for
foraging pollinators all kids have been
sorry but your ecology officer hasn't
even visited the site next slide a site
with no existing utilities only vague
plans for connection no cirrage
providing employment for one member of
staff would pass some help no current
plans for accommodation which does not
meet Defra guidance and BHS standards
questions are sustainability of this
operation the Planning Committee must
carry out a site visit to fully
understand the threat that the proposed
change of use presents you have to see
it to believe it
next slide highways have a duty of care
to keep roads as safe as possible this
application is a threat to the safety of
residents through increased traffic on a
narrow road with blind bends limited
pedestrian refuge and passing places
imagine reversing an articulated vehicle
in the dark with a foot wide verge
between you and the deep ditch vehicles
passing over soft verges transfer mud to
the carriageway with consequent danger
of skidding and collision see the
highways act 1981 bond up please now
thank you
you can finish your sentence off if you
want to sorry
you can finish your sentence off they've
been a number of accidents in this area
recently and it's only a matter of time
before there's a serious one involving a
pedestrian cyclist or horse rider and
they saw this application is flawed
please refuse it thank you the field
down question looks like it was grayza
bull how far would you like me to go
back that that of course is open village
regional foreign fields medieval fields
is enclosed in the
19th century I think and of course that
was for grazing it's being grazed by
horses
it was also grazed by a few cattle some
time ago okay I think it says in the
report this according to the parish cats
all it's been on the farm for
approximately 15 years it's that you
know in the report it says it's been
unfarmed for approximately grazing or
just ISM farm so know there's been
grazing on it okay thank you that came
from the parish council actually it
wasn't something car made up on the way
okay any further questions
no thank you
thank you and can we have our next
speaker which is Jamie Lee Henderson
dr. six minutes thank you good evening I
am here on behalf of my father mr. Paul
Henderson the applicant to speak in full
support of the application made I would
like to thank Stratford District Council
Planning Warwickshire County highways
and all respected bodies and agencies
for their positive responses the
proposed dwelling is situated
approximately 100 metres back from the
road in the northern corner of the site
the site is surrounded by mature
hedgerows and would be located
approximately 120 metres away from the
nearest property in the northwest the
proposal would promote acquire and
equestrian related activities involving
the provision of new buildings and
structures therefore complies with call
strategy policy AS 10 the stable link
will be constructed from wood in a
typical equestrian design and the site
largely Street from the road by large
hedgerow the parish council has objected
to the planning application one of the
reasons being the increase in traffic
volume and the unsuitability of the road
for the size and volume of traffic in a
letter dated 1st of June 2018 were
actually County Highways Authority
undertook a site visit and assessed the
information we have provided I cannot
confirm the exact assessment the
Warwickshire County highways made and
visiting the site however it was
confirmed the road is a public highway
and their conclusion was that subject to
the requirements outlined and
implemented the highways authorities
considered the principles of the
development proposed to be acceptable it
should be noted that there are in place
several accesses to fields along Axio
bridle road and there is a small holding
at the end of the world Road which would
suggest the current landowners used the
use the public highway regularly in a
letter day to 22nd of August 2018 from
Warwickshire can to council highways it
states that they have undertaken a full
assessment of the planning application
based on the assessment and appraisal of
the development proposed the highway or
forest has no objection to the planning
application subject to conditions if the
proposals will not generate a high
number of daily trips as the horses will
be on full
every they will be fully cared by one
member of staff in my experience on
livery yards most owners visit their
horses three to four times per week in
this setting due to working commitments
or placing their horses once retired
into this type of livery we estimate the
staff being ourselves to make around two
journeys per day morning and evening and
livery owners one like I say every three
to four days possibly more at the week
you'd expect to see more owners at the
weekend then certainly in the week I can
confirm we will not be taking any
deliveries of any types of fuel a feed
and water delivery will be limited to a
minimum number of journeys we estimate
approximately one per month which will
not be on Arctic lorries I should point
out that we intend to install mains
water and electricity on to the site as
soon as possible which would eliminate
the water delivery the management of
horse and human waste has also been
raised as a concern stratford district
council has been advised of our
intention to use a porta toilet which we
will be maintained on a regular basis
and human sewage taken from the site and
deposed off by the contractor this
course of action has been agreed in
principle by Stratford District Council
environmental health department the use
of a water dispenser will be fused for
human consumption and the horse waste
will be restored in a trailer and
removed from the site to prevent odors
and reduce any waste that could reach
that it the field is enclosed by mature
hedgerows which will limit the view
across the site and any visual impact of
the development the site is situated
within flood zone one areas deemed to be
in flood zone one have been shown to be
at less and naught point one percent
chance of flooding in any year the
development will be located outside of
the floodable area as the site the site
is potentially liable to surface water
however all our external surfaces will
be perma ball I would like to advise any
wildlife on the land will be given the
utmost respect and we have no intention
to remove any wildlife that resides on
the site the grazing will be landscaped
and maintained accordingly to keep in
character
the location the application for Philip
lights has also been raised as a concern
we would of course keep all external
lighting to a minimum as it is a very
quiet peaceful rural village and
sustainably source of the energy we do
not expect to use a lot of it so it
should be sustainably sourced and we
would put a strict implement strict
lighting policy on the land which meant
manage and external lighting we use
besime specific hours the applicant has
considered and confirmed as best to
planning policies we do hope that the
decision is a positive one by committee
members and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you start off with catch
the barns then catch the pack directly
opposite the field where we would have
our access there is an access to the
field directly opposite the current
landowner has a an access just before
our proposed access site and I believe
there is a third one as well for a field
situated next to the one opposite ours
but there is around three sorry well it
would be the where our gate we've
proposed is opposite another one okay
yep catch the powering thank you chair
good evening the Parish Council advised
that you hadn't that no consultation or
engagement had taken place with the
Parish Council obviously you were
perhaps aware of the concerns in the
village perhaps you can explain why no
engagement or consultation had taken
place with the parish council in all
honesty it's our first time we've ever
put in for planning so it has been a
very much a learning curve and I do at
most apologize if we didn't respond in
in an etiquette we should have we I
believe that all responses were made to
the letters as best that we could
if the council would like to sit down
with ourselves
if that is something we can do I
appreciate we are now at this stage but
if that is something that the council
would like we would be more than happy
to consolidate with them absolutely the
fielding one of the criteria as I
understand it I'm not into horses in any
way it's the fact that you should live
as near as possible to the Minhaj and to
the animals to keep an eye on them at
all times how far away will you be
living from from the site so we live in
longer Chintan which I believe is around
11 miles from the site currently which
is a considerable distance but we are
looking to relocate closer to the land
and I you know if the planning is
approved it would be s you know it
wouldn't be until next year we'd look to
develop the land after winter so it
gives us a considerable amount of time
to decide to relocate to be closest to
that horses and perhaps whales born or a
village politically you know peloton
priors closer to that but no decisions
have made as such as obviously the
planning has not being granted sorry
where you live in in long itching to do
you have horses there I do I have three
on a DIY livery so you want to you're
wanting to have your own stables in
other words we would have three of well
depending on how many we have it does
change we would have our own on there as
well as the livery so it would be always
be a maximum of eight livery / eight
horses and with the men arch there how
often you're going to allow people on to
exercise their horses and use the men
are it's appropriate use so people might
want to ride once a week people might
want to ride five times a week it would
depend the horse walker and the
surrounding bridle paths offer
alternative exercise but the minaj we
would you know in some of usage it's
fine there's no external lighting isn't
required you know we would certainly say
between the hours of 6:30 a.m. till 8:30
p.m. limit riding - and certainly in the
winter when lighting was required we
would have a strict policy to ensure
that the lights
weren't going to disturb any neighbors
or any villagers yeah just to make it
clear that the lighting is not part of
this scheme okay any any further
questions for the applicant no I'll
think you're free to go miss Anderson
Thank You warden and the place can't
slow down on
okay can slow down you've got five
minutes yeah would you like a warning
okay no problem what's not thank you
thank you chair committee members you
will know that I'm a huge supporter of
developing the rural economy and where I
can I fully get behind promoting rural
enterprise if it has to be the right
well-thought-out and appropriate rural
enterprise you will have heard that
there is a strong local opera's
opposition to this application and it is
a shame there was no engagement between
applicant and parish council it sounds
like that could now be alleviated I note
in Allison's well-written and balanced
report that she's trying to mitigate
some of these concerns including through
the inclusion of many conditions I'm not
sure if how many of you have visited the
site but those of you who have will know
about the blind bans and the narrow
nature of the Ox Hill bridle Road
lacking in passing places the passing
place referred to and accesses were
actually people's drives and also its
narrow width I walk the road on Friday
and there is much people horse dog
traffic but very few cars now cs1
encourages planning for people in a
social role to promote strong healthy
vibrant communities granting this
application with the increase in traffic
on a poor quality road as outlined so
clearly by both Rawls and Shawn will
negatively impact upon the popular
village walk used by dog walkers joggers
children learning to ride their bikes
and those simply out on a hack I would
strongly suggest that this is not
positively contributing to the
community's overall health and
well-being cs9
also advises that the development should
understand local context as it's key to
achieving good design now whilst the
design may be okay the local context in
this popular walk by locals they simply
wouldn't choose to regularly navigate
heavy vehicles on a single track Class E
Road which the need of repair with soft
and unstable verges as I walked with
both residents and parish council on
Friday we saw this large delivery lorry
which is very rare up that road and we
all had to move to the side of the soft
verge for it to pass if this is
problematic for walkers what will it be
like with increased car traffic in heavy
goods vehicles now whilst they do not
have a power
or village plan in peloton horsey they
do have a strong sense of how they want
their village to develop and remain and
we really should try and respect that
it's lack of service village status
reminds us that is an unsustainable
location and ideally any increase in
traffic would be towards the village
center and not up an unsuitable bridal
path they want to remain low on noise
and light pollution I note that alison
has recommended that there isn't any
flood lighting to maintain the low level
of light pollution now this is
reassuring however wearing my rural
economy hat it leads me to question how
profit or profitable a business will be
if consumers can only access their
horses in daylight hours if the business
were not to succeed would the
foundations be in place perhaps for
further development such as residential
for example perhaps a net coin tie might
be in order whilst considering the rural
enterprise element I am concerned that
we're valuable horses are being stabled
there is no overnight on-site management
or indeed mention of security especially
as we're being regularly updated on the
increase in rural crime also the lack of
concern about the fire water drainage
plow could suggest a lack of attention
to detail regarding safety not only for
this development but also neighboring
countryside and residents is 10 states
that development should minimize the
impact on occupiers and users of
existing properties in the area I
question how this can be possible when
neighboring drives are being suddenly
becoming passing places from marked
increase in heavy traffic
apart from horse owner vet farriers etc
due to the lack of amenities on-site
there is a regular delivery of water
feed and maintenance of the portable loo
now if the delivery of waters only wants
per month given the number of liters
required on a daily basis for horses it
would have to be either a very large
delivery or many of them a s10 also
states that development should avoid a
level of increase on rural roads that
would be harmful to the local area and I
argue that this current application
would be so given that the main concern
raised is the road leading to the site I
would request if possible that members
attend a site visit for themselves and
then perhaps discuss it further with
highways please do not follow the
opposite advice on this one and look to
refuse
thank you can slow down no I've got one
slight comment obviously can't slow down
all you do realize that we can only look
at this application that's in front of
us not take into account any potential
building of a residence afterwards so I
think you were aware enough no that's
why I didn't mention it Quint I just to
alleviate the fears the parish council
on that one thank you move on to points
of clarification case the Perry thank
you
the Parish Council I believe raised a
question of a charge on the land in
connection with Stratford district
council and the officer just put some
context into that and explained I seem
to prefer a question for monitoring
officer bouts a council tax charge I'm
not sure whether it was this one but the
actual points the council acts as many
hats so the council has to in some local
planning authority would have to
determine the application I don't see a
conflict between council tax and
planning no any points for the points of
clarification are also move on to the
debate the brain so I assume it's not an
adopted road
as far as I understand yes but I am not
aware of any plans they have to
undertake any maintenance on it right we
all happy should be going to the debate
who would like to start on this one
there okay so fielding I am concerned
about the nature of the ground on which
they are proposing to have their horses
there is it's scrubland on the southern
end of it which you can see clearly from
the road the other end of it is rather
difficult to see into the field but if
it's what they say is full of permanent
pasture rich in furrow then is it going
to be well they're going to have to
damage some of it to create the entrance
into the into the Minhaj and the other
areas I'm loathe to see something that
has got so much wildlife being turned
into a site like this
Kevin I think there are a number of
concerns about this application as it
stands I'm not saying they can't be
resolved but I'm very reluctant to grant
planning permission this evening for
three reasons
two of these are actually on the update
sheet we've had representations from
seven Trent about sewage and sewage
disposal and clearly this can be done
through septic tanks but they require
quite big vehicles to get down there and
empty them so consequently there are
issues to resolve with seven Trent
before I think any application here is
worthy of approval now then you go on to
number two which includes lighting and
we're told that effectively that we're
not being asked to approve lighting but
we do have a situation whereby the
facilities that I'm a little used to
this because my son was in their horse
riding and various things and in winter
in the dawn of dark afternoons main
arches would need to be lit therefore it
probably isn't practical for the
applicant to have an approval that
doesn't in fact include some issue over
lighting and that would have to be dealt
with quite separately if it's not
included in the recommendation so that's
another reason not to grant that this
evening the third thing is I did
actually take a drive down there and I
noticed the lack of parking spaces and
when you get off the metal road onto the
e-class track you know there is no width
the passing places are people's gateways
so therefore they don't count as passing
places and there will be some fairly
hefty vehicles
coming through unpredictable times that
wouldn't be able to pass each other you
know I take the point made by the war
member on her country ramble down there
on Friday but the situation is that you
know if you drive around Cornwall I'm
getting a little bit of experience of
Cornwall because my daughter's just
moved there there's lots of narrow lanes
with high hedges and somehow or other
traffic moves around that's a similar
feature to down here in the situation
where traffic I think will be heavily
constrained therefore my instinct is to
defer this application Thank You chair
it's quite rare that we get an
application where there is so much local
objection to a particular application
for various reasons because I've been
away I haven't been able to go to see
the site obviously the way the the
proposals are presented at the moment we
don't have an objection from highways
but I feel that in view of the points
that Council O'Donnell has made in
particular reference to CS 9 and a s 10
that I think we need I think we deserve
it to the local community to go and
defer this and go and have a proper look
at it and therefore I would be putting
forward a proposal to defer on on the
grounds that I think particularly
because the applicant is it's already
been mentioned this evening that the
applicant hasn't wasn't aware that they
should be engaging with the parish
council I think if we were to defer this
it would enable the parish council and
the applicant to have a more detailed
conversation together and I would like
to see the highways representative
actually come on - an official site
visit so I've been putting a
recommendation to defer sir Barnes
well as I'm concerned it's an
unsustainable sight for livestock if
they live in 12 miles away it's against
my insurance policy
what theirs is I don't know if there was
a house on the application like an Perry
said there more work needs to be done I
think we might be able to look at it but
as far as I'm concerned it's leaving
horses out there with the rural crime
there is would be cruel any any other
comments its location we usually get her
nose or somebody to look at these sort
of applications to see if they're viable
and I don't think it's viable or
sustainable with the location of 11
miles between where the management will
be an auroral isolated locations on with
potentially barns on this we might look
what the one lady she's in I'm quite
happy to propose that
I agree with my colleagues on other side
of meat it is unsustainable and it is a
sight that and the side of me that I
would like to see a site visit but I
leave it to the vote so we we've had a
cancer brain yes if cancer Barnes's
proposal was to refuse I was second now
can I just clarify no my proposal was to
defer to be able to go and actually have
a look so that we got highways
representative up there first have we
got a seconder for a deferral cancer
site so we need to vote on that whether
you're happy to support cancer Perris
requests referral all those in favor for
chairman those against abstentions two
abstentions
yes thank you
[Music]
spare weather sassette would just check
a nickel for the facts
right we're just checking out one to two
things
okay so barn sorry yeah we're just
checking a couple of facts and the basis
of the deferral is that we'll need more
information from County highways and we
can also clarify the lighting scheme as
well as well as the seven Trent water
issue with with the tax so there's three
issues that it needs to confirm and get
accurate information on so on that basis
as long as if it was happy with that and
I can see quite a few people nodded I'm
happy to recommend sorry state so we're
just clarified it's those three issues
and the application is it has been
deferred so thank you for that yes yes
art this is as well yeah sorry so thank
you for that
Kent sir I don't know if you'd like to
come back
right thank you very much again will new
move on to our next item which is 18 / 0
1 8 6 fu up 6 0 ful lower grounds Main
Street middle ty so full application for
a stable and we've got Allison again
once sorry Allison our moves ahead a bit
quickly there
Thank You mr. chairman the application
site is situated situated between middle
and lower timezone as shown by the black
dot the application site involves the
relocation of an existing private stable
and a new gated access and associated
access Drive there is a public
right-of-way along the western boundary
of the site and a bridle way to the
northern boundary here is an aerial view
of the site showing the location of the
use existing stables at the red arrow
and the proposed new location at the
yellow arrow the aerial photograph is
slightly out of date as the plot to the
south has been completed with five new
houses in addition to the existing
dwelling lower grounds this is a plan
showing the proposed layout with the
stables relocated to the rear of the
field approximately hundred metres from
the road and a new access from the main
road it is in its existing position the
stables is approximately 12 meters from
the nearest house on Red Horse close in
its new position it would be
approximately 24 meters away from the
same house this slide shows the layout
plan that was approved previously this
permission expired on the 4th of March
2017 the proposed location location and
access of the stables is the same this
slide shows plans and the saree
elevations of the stables fairly typical
design four meters to the ridge 2.2
meters to the eaves and this shows the
slide shows the view of the application
site on the outskirts of Tai so with the
stables at the existing stables at the
red arrow and the proposed relocation
site at the yellow arrow there are no
updates mr. chairman and the
recommendation is to approve the
application for the reason detailed in
the report thank you we'll move on to
our first
because just cuts the Graham Collier
from Tysoe Parish Council
good evening mr. Collier how are you
good good that's it Thank You Vince
would you like a warning maybe wise
thank you very much I thank you chairman
good evening councilors I'm Ty surprise
council objects strongly to this
planning application the reasons being
the proposed structure is outside the
building line it's as an outward
extension of the village boundary with a
new access to in open countryside and
removal of a hedgerow all within sight
of the air nor be no good reason is
offered for the proposed driveway and
stables for which there is no natural
screening the harm they will bring two
views from the a and B outweighs any
benefit from the development the
proposal therefore contravenes core
strategy policy CS 11 the proposed
development does not accord with key
objectives with the emerging Nebel plan
which is moving towards the submission
stage this is because it is outside the
proposed built-up area boundary for
middle and appetizer it risks the
coalescence of middle tile and the
hamlet of law I saw thereby threatening
to destroy the open countryside between
the distinct and separate two
settlements we saw neighborhood plan
seeks to preserve and thus accord with
the requirements of course such as a
policy CS 15 the proposed development
extends into open countryside and is
therefore inappropriate is described in
core strategy policy as 10 the immunity
value of neighboring dwellings
constructed since the approval of the
exploit planning application 13 /l 3 263
ful is prejudiced by the proposed
development examples to which these
residents cannot object
seemingly by covenant imposed by the
applicant are intrusive lighting
vehicle and other noise from the
proposed driveway and hence rodent
activity unpleasant odors
as there is no provision for the storage
and removal of manures in summary title
price counsel objects this planning
application because it is an outward
extension of the village boundary it
fails to respect the ARB and the views
from it it contradicts key objectives of
titles advanced emerging neighborhood
plan it is in contravention of policies
with instructed districts called
strategy it prejudices the immunity of
value of the recently constructed
neighboring dwellings in red halls close
and it compromises the welfare and
security of the horses and associated
equipment by located locating the
stables too far away from the house to
which they are presently connected title
price counsel asks therefore that this
planning 30 seconds refused the
application which is totally
inappropriate for the developments
intended location thank you thank you
mr. Pollock mr. twenty seconds to spare
very good
any questions for the bars counsel place
no thanks cast aside just in time please
can we go back to the aerial photograph
please now just above the tail of the
red arrow is a line a hedgerow across
that field there is just a fence thank
you so there's no water course I don't
think going that right I'm pretty pretty
sure there's not an answer now because
the green bit between the application
site and the rest of the village will be
because which has been the subject of a
considerable amount of controversy it
has indeed it does indeed and this this
adds to that controversy
well I wasn't necessarily trying to lead
you on that but it seems to me that the
site that's got the green and the red
arrows in it contains this new access
road no the new access road is in is
within the development of the of the
kendrick housing development there is no
there is a there is an entrance to this
field on the opposite end to where the
proposed driveway where they're
proposing to put the driveway right so
the blue line he's probably the thing we
couldn't decide whether it was a or
offense or whatever just now the blue
line to the right is a hedge and by
footpath always his and the red line at
the back I believe is just fence from
what I saw today right since there is no
screening for the natural screening so
the parish council are objecting because
this site is outside the proposed
built-up area boundary yes yeah and this
is also in open green space yeah I think
I think you've answered the question
fully thanks very much any any further
questions right thank you mr. Colin yeah
that's pretty good
you move on to our next speaker which is
catch the fielding furling you've got
five minutes
the basically because a concern about
this road is a proposal that has now
been refused which you can see the the
black air area all the houses that were
part of the Kendricks site and the site
to the left of that is now and has got
Planning Commission on it the concern
was that the landowner I think wanted to
move away from the land that he'd sell
to the Kendricks site so he offered to
put in some low cost terraced houses and
on the right-hand side of the track a
larger house for his accommodation
now that was refused withdrawn and
refused
sorry was refused by buying the planners
and at the same time that it was being
refused he put in this application to
move as it says in the documentation the
stable that was behind his can you go
back can you go back to the aerial view
or the last one no going back
there the weather red arrow is is the
existing stable block that he proposed
to move basically I although I haven't
seen it I have been told that it is
fairly decrepid it fairly de krappa
dated says he getting his trunk in its
teeth around the word and would not move
to the new area where the yellow arrow
is so therefore he's proposing a totally
new building for animals and stock and
horses that have never been known to be
owned or on this site by the current
owner
so therefore the village is concerned
and also leading to the area between the
two areas of habitation lower and upper
middle tighter and lower ties so where
the village do want to keep a Greenfield
area or green area so basically that is
the reason why I asked that it is
refused Thank You cancer fielding any
questions for the ward member Chancellor
Perry thank you John the current stable
block you say it's very dilapidated I
just wondered whether you'd had any you
know had there been any thoughts to do a
replacement dwelling a replacement
stables on that particular site as far
as I'm aware no he want basically he
wanted to put that tract in and put a
stable at the far end there that was I
think you've answered the question there
Cody thank you very much for you to go
right points of clarification any any
points of clarification for the offices
no gone Lincoln safari just in time
again that's alright
can the officers just advise the wait we
can give in terms of harm for proposed
development outside the built-up area
boundary the built-up area boundaries
are still proposed so the amount that
you can Accord to the the built-up area
boundaries limited currently
catch the st. George garnets to the bike
now any points of clarification you put
your speaker on please surprised by
lessons comment because as people know I
was out of action rather poorly for most
of the summer and we done all the
built-up area boundary work prior to
that illness of mine and I thought we
got to the stage where they had been
adopted so I don't wish to have an open
confrontation with the officers over
this but I challenge statement
Karen will come back without if she
would please yeah I think two points of
clarification one the tie so
neighborhood plan is an emerging plan
they so therefore it has limited weight
this is a proposal for a stable building
and therefore in terms of the built-up
area boundary we wouldn't normally be
applied the policy wouldn't normally a
plant be applied in that way in that
this is not a residential or commercial
proposal it's a private stables and the
other thing I would draw your attention
to on page 26 top of the page the
planning history of the site this
development is has previously had a
Planning Commission I appreciate that
spree core strategy but planning
permission was granted in 2014 for
exactly for this proposal and that is a
material consideration
we okay should we go on to the debate
there cancer part certainly points of
clarification moment 13:03 two six three
four in the same location the layout
planned from the 2014 application and
the current application and you can see
side by side that the stables is in the
same position in both applications and
the new access is in the same same
location Thank You Alan that's very
clear right
can I just closed it can support no
qualms no hunt finish yep and catch the
st. of you indicating no could you turn
your light off please
right thank you should we move on to the
debate now cancel Perry thank you
Thank You chairman whilst I have every
sympathy with the parish council for
their concerns about this particular
application based on the officers
confirmation of the situation regarding
the built up area boundary and
highlighting the previous planning
application I can't find a serious
planning material planning with reason
to refuse this that would not be
overturn it would be easy overturned at
appeal therefore not wishing to go
against the parish council I'm going to
go with the officers recommendation
because I can't see any reason to put
forward a refusal on this particular
application thank you
that's the bonds I'm quite happy to be
sitting the proposal along with the
opposite recommendation we've had a
proposal and a seconder unless anybody
else should we go to the vote all those
in favor you know mr. chairman committee
resolves to grant application 18 / 0 1 8
6 0 ful thank you
yeah okay right sir
move on to the next item on the agenda
which is 18 / 0 2 2 4 1 ful the king
said hotels
Charcot Road was born external
alterations to include removal of 20
twentieth-century porch and
reconfiguration of external customer
garden to what road frontage this
demerit listed building consent
application 17/8 ooh double 3 2 /r busi
granted third of May in 2018 presented
officer is Matthew coin Thank You
chairman yeah you may remember this
one's been to committee before so the
application site is relates to a pub in
Wales born it's indicated by the black
dot in the center of the screen there so
the the pub itself is a great - listed
building it's shown within the center of
the screen there the site itself
encompasses the the land at red it's
also within the designated conservation
area in close proximity to another run
other listed buildings sorry including
the church which is very - stylists to
build in so there's a as two accesses
off of the b4 over 86
that's the the Warren Road at the other
site there and then there's sort of an
entrance to the side of the property
here from Church Street so this is the
view looking at the pub from the warrant
Road entrance you can see one of the
accesses in a foreground here the porch
which is the subject of this application
is this sort of element here this is
them panning around to the left with an
area of seating in front to the pub
which is proposed to be grasped so this
is a view from the church Street
application the chap street views are
with the entrance just in the behind
that the vehicles there
this view is also looking at the sort of
the entrance from the Church Street from
within the sort of the grounds of the
pub okay so the the this is the existing
block plan and then this is the proposed
block plan so that this application
mainly deals with of three three
elements the removal of the porch to
this side of the property some
reconfiguration of the car parking
spaces so I think there's there's a loss
of two from this this location here you
can see them removed there but they gain
one disabled space within the parking
area here and there's also some
landscaping changes so this is the the
existing plan and the proposed plan the
only change really on on here that's
worth of notes is the the removal of the
porch the internal works have all been
covered by the discipline concern
already granted so the existing
elevations and the proposal evasions you
can see predominantly on this this area
of the screen here and that's where the
change takes place and the removal of
that porch element and that's it there's
a couple of updates for you
the one of the proposed conditions ii
believe it's condition for yeah so
proposed condition number four relates
to a schedule of works that's all
covered by the listed building consent
already so we don't believe that's
necessary on this on this application
there was a consultation from seventh
rent it suggested informative so I've
included that in the update sheet
I've also also worried that there's
comment to external lighting within the
report whilst it's not formed what it
doesn't form part my recommendation
there is some standard wording on there
she remembers be minded to approve the
application so you know the
recommendation is to prove it subject to
six can
sessions with omission of condition for
on the on the agenda and two notes with
the inclusion of the second world from
seventh Rena we move on to our first
speaker which is mr. Richard Colley Mr
Colley good evening thank you three men
three minutes again would you like a
warning with 30 seconds to go
yes please thank you far away can I
start by saying I have no objection to
the applicants desire to successfully
improve the king's head hotel as long as
the main entrance always remains in
chocolate road and there's no
significant increase in the number of
covers or pay more increase in parking
issues as you were though was a previous
application which was rejected by his
committee on two principle grounds one
with regards to highway safety issues
but there was also four because of
causing harm to the minuting of
neighboring residents by virtue of
change of status of the main entrance in
this otherwise predominately residential
area and failure to comply with policy
cs9 SES 26 the only major change in this
resubmitted application has been to
remove the highway safety issue and no
further change is made to clarify how
the chocolate Road entrances would be
arranged and protect the immunity of
neighbors for example the main entrance
if it remains on Parker Road there
should be no need to remove the internal
lobby from the chocolate road entrance
and create an internal lobby for
secondary entrance in Church Street and
which or the requirement for any loss of
any car park spaces could I request the
committee consider planning conditions
to ensure that the charcut Road front
entrance is operated as a main entrance
at all times and kept open in doing a
normal run for operating hours and not
the Church Street entrance if you look
at the neighboring bargain booze
approval that application approved 30
I had conditions attached to it such
that customers weren't allowed to enter
the premises after 2300 and that there
any all delivery should only take place
between the hours of 12 and 20 hundred
so I should think that the we are good
conditions that I had that the church
retention should not be used after 2300
there's also a proposal the applicant
requests that this is the limited
refurbishment of the king's head in
order to upgrade the operation and keep
it relevant to its customer base hi
another residents of spoken to Andy
Coombs the manager and he's quite open
the only reason M&B want to move the
main entrance to Church Street is to
increase the number of covers from circa
100 284 the avoidance of doubt could it
condition be added to ensure no vin teal
increase and another number of current
covers so are 3.1 I understand the
recommend ability surgeons sorry okay
the planning team recommends that 30
space satiric works I understand that
the March there was a draft SPD which
required five space five square metres
of internal space which would require
sixty scarf park spaces if you look up
here currently there are twelve spaces
outside the pub and if you go to or the
King's Head Hotel if you look at the
final one the actual number of spaces
lost is six not the the one NetCast base
that's considered because there's three
thank you very much thank you very much
that's most kind any questions please
fill Mr Colley okay so fielding I got
lost between dealing with the front and
the back which are two separate
applications we're having to deal with
today we agree basically I'm happy that
the porch is removed and I understand
about the car parking but you you've
gone on about the the front porch is
that big is that because it's going to
leave a gap in the front there or what
why you against the previous application
made changes to an internal side of the
building by making a larger entrance
Church trees if this application was
resubmitted on the basis of this is
separate from the next application we'll
consider which is the church tree there
should be a focus on the entrance from
charcut Road but there's been no changes
from the previous application site yes
chairman we actually used to have
planning committee meetings in the
church fall behind there and therefore
would frequent the Kings head more often
than we do now I remember those days
and one or two others might recall them
as well but the situation is that I
think we then used to go in through the
Church Street entrance but I I think we
ought to deal with this whole thing
there's two separate applications one
for the front and one for the back
because I'm quite happily direct people
to the front entrance but I can't see
why can you just just yes please if you
could just firm up your question please
I think I could see where you were going
yes Mr Colley architectural II it is not
very good but the this planning
application concerned is exactly the
same as the previous one if the front
entrance remains in childhood Road it
needs an internal lobby on that side of
the building not creating a new one at
the back of the building for a secondary
entrance it's pretty clear thank you
very much
right step no further questions you're
free to go mr. Kearney think move on to
our next speaker which is our ward
number
no mr. data's not here oh come on mr.
Davi sorry about that case of panic so I
was advised Yeah right
it's got three minutes mr. Damon thank
you and thank you for indulging sir
first of all I'm being guy that planning
committee is running late mr. Kali is
quite right this is a very similar
application almost identical to the
application that the council had before
it's a few months ago we have for this
application however removed the changes
which were proposed to the Church Street
the grounds in front of the church
streets elevation and to the church
elevation itself what this application
seeks to do is basically obtain Planning
Commission for something that your
council is already granted listed
building consent for we start involved
taking down and modifying the rear
elevation and mr. Kali referring to a
new internal porch of the Church Street
elevation that's not part of this
application because it doesn't need
planning permission it suppose it
doesn't need planning permission
the only needs listed building consent
and your council has already granted
that listed building consent so the
application does not propose any changes
to Church Street it's just proposed
these changes at the back and to the new
garden the company wants to invest in
this property making more attractive and
secure long-term future and it wants to
improve all the entrances to the
building that's why we want to take down
that rather ugly and domineering rear
entrance the rear entrance from Charcot
Road that will stay there currently
three entrances into the building two on
this elevation one on the church street
side they're all going to stay there all
be open through all of them right
through trading that's really just what
I wanted to emphasize that this is an
application that simply brings the
planning permission into line with a
listed building consent so that the
companies can then get on and refurbish
this building we understand there are
proposals or the main concern is about
more activity at Church Street frontage
and that's why we split the application
so that can be considered as part of the
second application thank you
right any questions mr. Barnes could you
we have what we try to do is split out
the issue the only issue and I was here
but a large committee the main issue was
about additional potential additional
activity on the church Street frontage
so this application takes that out no
changes are proposed on the church
Street elevation as part of this
application that's the second
application you'll be debating later
today and we have made some changes
which I'll address when we get before
that application well you can count the
number of covers on the plans their
existing proposed to the ground that
customer trade area does not change at
all there's no increase it's the same
area that the customers have got access
to they will have access to the moment
how the come the company then lays it
out and what size tables and chairs are
use it's not a planning matter it's not
a little spin listed building matter it
shouldn't be for this committee to
consider it's not material before which
last time which is the front and which
is the back the front as far as we were
all led to we're just looking at
alterations to the front of the building
it's - yes getting - okay the the front
the front from the charcut Road or that
building sorry that a porch in the front
there was as far as we were concerned
the front of the building
and but I understand that why you need
to get rid of it it's not like the the
best is this basically have you changed
what you're looking at whether
this is the front or the back I mean
frankly it doesn't matter there are
three entrances into this building
historically the oldest part of the
building is a part freight facing Church
Street that's why it's listed and the
listing refers to that porch on the
front of the shirt Street elevation so
factually it's historically correct to
say that's the front elevation of the
building the way it's operated over the
last hundred years that the operation
has flipped and most people now come in
from this elevation whether you call at
the front or the back it's immaterial
really all these entrances and this one
will stay is not being reduced in size
all we're doing is taking the brick arch
off it and improving the appearance so
you can actually see the back of the
building and the nice 19th century
gables and we're trying to improve how
this building looks at from all angles
and and improve how customers enter it
from whichever direction their approach
was advised earlier wasn't that's right
try and keep to my five minutes and I
would just like to say that I the the
parish council had advised that they'd
registered me to speak in their slot but
obviously for for one reason or another
I no committee services haven't received
it so I will just make some reference to
what they wanted it that's ok I'm happy
about
thank you well firstly I'd like just
like to emphasize that I'm not against
development on this site but any
development to the Kings head needs to
protect the heritage and history of the
site and be founded on the facts that
are correct the biggest issue with this
application is it should never have been
validated because of the errors and
inaccuracies in the actual design and
access statement
which refers to two frontages the
building has never had two frontages and
that is where all the confusion has come
through utter planning in architectural
level but the design and access
statement for this application refers to
two frontages one on shelf cat road and
one in Church Street which are
fundamentally incorrect the King's Head
frontage is to child cat Road and the
rear entrance backs onto Church Street
the inference that our two frontages
therefore totally invalidates this
application the fact that the applicants
agent is based in Essex means that
unfortunately their local knowledge is
rather limited the original entrance has
never been on Church Street and it is
clearly wrong to be changing the
orientation of the property in this
respect as it will clearly have an
adverse effect on the residential
amenity of the adjacent properties and
neighborhood by reason of noise and
disturbance there is clear evidence that
the frontage to the King's Head ease off
child cut road and not Church Street and
I just want to really emphasize that
therefore my objections reflect on the
the development on the character of the
neighborhood because of creating a front
entrance at the rear of the building
appreciate we're talking about the front
entrance here it's unfortunate that
we've got two separate applications
about the same site it's very confusing
for everybody so in terms of design and
distinctiveness we need to have
sensitivity to the proposals including
the layout and the orientation to the
setting neighboring uses landscape
character of the site and locality as I
said at the beginning I do wish to
emphasize we are not against development
of this site it just has got to be
correct and therefore keen for a
condition to insist that this child cut
road entrance is used as a main entrance
and it can be conditioned on terms of
exit and hours in terms of the parish
council
they were most confused by this because
it followed lbc consent and they were
just completely at sea as to how how
they should really respond I would also
like to say they are increasingly
dissatisfied by the development plan
because it's come through in so many
different stages causing them great
confusion
their main concern River it lates to the
relocation of the main entrance into
Church Street and they say this
application came before us at a comp but
as a copy of a previous one to fill the
obligation under the LBC an ordinary
planning consent the parrot parish
council has been unhappy about the
piecemeal application and has made
representation to SDC regarding this
these two applications are examples of
this when we discuss this application
council voted against it but were in the
position of not finding a way to object
given that it had already been agreed
and this was a formality council was
against the reciting of the main
entrance that was just their comments
thank you Karen you move on to again
this off see quite quite a complex
subject can we have any points of
clarification we have we won two or
three applications yes so you've got two
applications before you I think they
they were submitted concurrently see
they were submitted at the same time but
they the development has separated out
the elements that they believed were
unconscious from the earlier discussions
so that was the removal of the porch the
landscaping to the
to the property in an attempt to get
approval on those matters and then for a
separate debate to take place on the
more contentious issues which were to
the rear of the property or to the
Church Street side of the property
should I say and I think those matters
need to be considered separately tonight
so the the application that you're
considering at the moment is just for
the alterations to the this side of the
property I've got a small question and
obviously conditions Matthew they have
to be proportionate and reasonable I
think it was Mr Colley it might be
councillors saying so apologies about
entrance off I mean at the moment that
the the use of the pub itself isn't
restricted so I don't think it would be
reasonable both entrances on both sides
of the property are open until closing
time off off the pub so I don't think it
would be reasonable to close one of
those by way of condition at this time
any points of clarification no should we
move on to the debate on this one case
the fielding basically I propose that we
go ahead with the recommendations of the
planners that we remove that Porsche
it's not the nicest and that is what I
proposed how cancer brain sorry cancer
bonds
sorry can so who are you only doing it
once oh I'm quite a bit a second we've
had a proposer in a second
and obviously are you happy too that we
move condition for as well and happy to
agree the updates regarding seventh rent
water the lighting as well so we've had
a proposal in a seconder on that one all
those in favor for chairman those
against one chairman Epstein committee
resolves to grant application 18 / 0 2 2
4 1 ful and we'll move on to item number
7 to go yep okay thank you for coming
recover quickly
okay so when they move on to item number
seven which is 18 / 0 2 2 4 2 ful again
King said no chocolate right yes thank
you Kevin I'll just quickly run through
the first few sides may I see the sites
in Wales born again it's a listed
building great sue in the conservation
area number of other listed buildings
surrounding the property so the site's
indicated by the red arrow so this photo
just demonstrates the existing
arrangement from the corner of the
carpark looking along the side of the
property so there's a picket fence gate
and then that's again looking down the
side of the property towards Church
Street you'll notice this or the smoking
shelter sort of in the center of the
screen there and that's proposed for
removal comes out later so this is
looking towards the church Street
entrance of the pub and the porch on
that side of the property there is a
picket fence gate on there that does
lead directly into the the port so
that's again looking from church tree
back towards the property on the right
hand side is the the entrance and the
porch on that side of the property and
again the same sort of view that so
again this applicator this application
mainly relates to the landscaping works
on the south east western side of the
property sorry and basically increasing
the the movement or the ability to walk
along the side of the property to this
entrance so it's mainly just landscaping
upgrading of the path and an arbor in
that location sort of just there there
are no updates for members tonight and
the application is recommended for
approval for the reasons set out in the
agenda thank you
Thank You Matthew
move on to our first speaker
is mr. Koh again
okay mr. golly thank you very much
object this second application which
seeks to move the principle registered
entrance of the charcut road to church
street which is a car cul-de-sac
residential street leading the church
the King Church Street entrance has
never been the front or main entrance to
the king's head hotel slide one point
one above here shows the king said hotel
from the charcut road in circa 1920
there's a car outside there but also on
the right you've got the stables you've
got full signage it's on on main roads
next slide please
the king's head was owned by the new
suits of charkha park and was developed
in the early nineteenth century for the
two tall robes you got the main
birmingham to london toll road that went
through warwick through wells born to
clinton and then you had the main
nottingham to to two-bath main road and
that the pub is actually built at a
junction so there's actually no way
anybody would develop hotel and coaching
anywhere else
deftly not on Church Street next slide
this is Church Street in 1910 you can
see the amount of footfall there's grass
growing outside that entrance he's never
been a main entrance it's a secondary
entrance from people coming from the
church or from the village just walking
can their only entry I can find that
says Church Street was elicited was I
was the main entrance was in an
erroneous listing and that was done in
August 1971 when about forty properties
in wells well were listed in a drive-by
listing I understand from two experts
the work in conservation but these are
notoriously inaccurate and that if they
ever found one they would always find an
alternative source to check that it was
correct none has been provided in
addition in the Wells one Conservation
Area report adopted by stratford-on-avon
District Council in the early 90s it's
clear the king's head hotel faces
chocolate Road
slide 2.1 please
I don't understand the planning teams
recommendation 30 spice spaces are
sufficient because I mentioned in March
the draft SPT considered that five once
space was required for every five square
meters so this would be 60
it's like 2.2 currently so I can just go
back one actually I just jumped ahead
too much you can currently see there's
three disabled and three ordinary car
park spaces at the bottom and six where
the proposed Arbor is can you get its
next slide this is a proposal it
actually takes out six car park spaces
and not a net one as per the application
or of case offices so can i I think any
review any lots of spaces should be
refused can we go to the next slide okay
yeah this is the final slide this is the
what was included the listed building
consent as an approved plan and there is
absolutely no arbor in that plan so it's
in concert this application is an
opposite to what that listed building
consent approval was thank you very much
just come on fight obviously you went
through that one quite quickly the
decision in respect of 1702 three three
two listed building consent specifically
approved plans and drawings in in that
consent it specifically listed plan 1178
ten F external scope of works revised
are set out this is a copy of extract of
it you can see there's no large harbor
in that listed building consent this
planning application puts Ann Arbor in
which is in contravention to that mister
building at the center thank you
further questions to mr. Coyne no Priya
thank you very much now we'll go back to
mr. Davi
thank you again members um I'll be quick
and if I may I'll deal with the last
point raised by mr. Kali first he's
quite right the listed building consent
you've granted does not include naba
that's because it's a free-standing
structure and does not need listed
building consent none of the works that
are part of this proposal need listed
building consent they don't affect the
structure and fabric of the building
itself
they just affect the grounds we only
need planning permission the reason we
split the applications was when I was at
the previous committee it was out or my
understanding that these were the
contentious issues it was the
improvement of the route from the car
park to the Church Street entrance
whether or not you want to call it the
front the back the secondary the primary
the fact is the entrance is there and
we're not ordering it whatsoever we're
not touching that entrance any of the
fabric it stays it is every door every
hinge every doorknob doesn't get altered
this application simply seeks to improve
the way that customers enter this
entrance of the building we've done a
similar thing at the front we've
improved the rear garden and landscape
to it and we'd like to do the same at
the front the a rather rough gravel
surface would like to pay that we would
like to put a few bollards along the
line and we'd like to put an arbor at
the entrance that is the full extent of
this proposal now you see there's a lots
of tables and chairs out there none of
that requires permission if we have
customers walking all through this way
it's a more of a formal entrance or
another alternative entrance into the
building we'll have to remove some of
those tables and chairs so there'll be
less activity at the back and this
should be to the benefit of the
residents it is fully supported by your
conservation officers he thinks he'll
improve the setting of the building and
the conservation area and unless you
have any further questions
and whoever cares the Perry please
and again if you work on the basis that
you include your comments from the
parish counselor as well
Thank You chair well once again I've got
no objection to the applicants plans to
refurbish the sort of interior features
the king said providing the covers
remain at the proposed levels maximum
100 essentially what we have here is
with all the various changes the
provision of parking concerned about the
loss of parking and the provision of
parking for pub restaurants on hotels
was highlighted in the SDC supplementary
planning document dated March 2018 which
emphasizes the need to provide one space
per five square metres of the indoor
customer area and one space per
allocated bedroom there are actually
nine bedrooms and I had this confirmed
by the planning consultants yesterday
unfortunately we're unable to give me
the precise square footage of the
customer indoor area but that might be
something you wish to pick up on the
main concern that I have again comes
back to the fact that it's imperative
that the front entrance to the Kings
head is not created in Church Street my
concern with these proposed plans is
that with the pedestrian access route
from the carpark to the rear entry rear
entrance with bollard lights clearly
focusing on making the rear entrance the
front entrance this is a major concern
and obviously as highlighted by Mr
Colley the the main difference between
the previous application in this one
with the LBC was the fact that they've
been now and incorporated a large Arbor
which therefore automatically will
direct more people back into this Church
Street entrance the fact that you've got
bollard lighting lighting the whole
pedestrian way from the car
you know they're not going to be
directed to the child cut entrance
they're going to be specifically
directed to the church Street entrance
so at the end of the day my main
objections are affected the development
of the character of the neighborhood
this is going to have a huge impact on
all the residents who live in Church
Street where parking is that are
complete it's minimal now we have lots
of events going on at the church and the
church room and it is a real adverse
effect of the residential amenity in
terms of what the parish council had to
say they objected to this planning
application on the grounds that a
non-essential structure leading to a new
path through the garden area to the
recited entrance leads to the loss of
four parking spaces
I draw your attention to the SPD
criteria on parking where there should
be at least 60 car parking spaces for a
commercial enterprise of this nature the
applicant has made statements that this
development is to enhance the facilities
it offers to its users and that it plans
to increase its covers in the restaurant
by 80 given that this is the case and
given the restricted parking available
in the area and the dependence of the
facility upon its car parking facilities
to accommodate this increase in users
the loss of these spaces for a
non-essential structure seems
inconsistent so the parish council have
also got major concerns on the parking
you may remember the committee approved
planning permission for a 40 restaurant
in in actually child cut Road literally
50 yards from this development parking
is at a premium well spawn and to
encourage the front entrance in Church
Street is just going to completely block
the whole of the residential amenity I
do ask you to seriously consider
refusing this application thank you
I lived in in Church Street and that the
parking area around the back though was
taken up as much by people who were
walking along the footpath or game to
the church as there were people drinking
there is it your opinion that it has
changed is it the same as I remember
there are in fact less parking spaces
because there have been four additional
residential developments actually built
in Church Street with very limited
parking so we have a problem where it's
only one single file traffic can go up
and down Church Street because the cars
are either side questions and it's
mentioned of the parish council
somewhere yeah it's right in where the
king's head church street is in the
heart of the conservation area of well
spawn and the other thing that's
important is is the the listing with
historic England actually have got the
wrong listing in Church Street it should
refer to the front as being child cut
road okay thank you thank you very much
Costa Perry move on two points of
clarification I've got a couple Matthew
to do with the parking the SPD a
material is the parking issue regarding
the pedestrian routes to this
application so the the SPD's got limited
way at the moment it's not adopted
I think the the other important thing to
note is that the SPD is relates to new
developments this is an existing
building so you wouldn't impose the
parking standards
as you were if it would a new
development she want to comment on that
counts this ain't no I disagree with the
case officer and move on to the debate
he wants to start on this one cants the
brain perspective it's work to improve
an existing pedestrian route between the
main carpenter tree it's nothing to do
with covers it's nothing to do with
bedrooms as long as I've known the
premises and I knew when I was a police
officer that's the licensing officer
that it's always had two entrances I
think we just need to get on with this
and I propose we go with the officers
recommendation I believe that the doing
away with a car parking to the the side
of the building there is wrong all its
going to do is to force people to park
in Cho Street do away with the Arbor and
I'm quite happy if those are the
conditions that we can go forward on to
support cancer brain cancer Brian it's
written by the officers thank you that's
the st. I come from a different
perspective than my two colleagues
because I think that parking is a very
strong concision and I'm alarmed because
everybody's aware of my illness is this
year and they date from the 21st of
April that's the day I was carried off
in you know by the paramedics but
effectively we not only approved the SPD
for consultation back in March we also
through the cabinet that I then shared
we actually passed the parking rules in
order to give them more weight so I'm
afraid I dislike case officers trying to
diss
them as having limited weight and I hope
he's not going to accuse me like I was
accused recently of treating officers
with disrespect for saying making a
statement like that because quite
frankly I have to tell you as it comes
and therefore and I remember those days
when the Planning Committee used to meet
in the church hall and we had parking
spaces down by the side of the hall we
didn't park in Church Street but plenty
of other people did and I think there's
a serious issue we must orientate the
front of the building so it meets in
child cut Road that's the entrance that
won't stop people using the rear
entrance but I don't give as much weight
to that as councilor brain house I think
we should make certain these available
but it's not encouraged and therefore on
with councilor Perry on this whole issue
and her approach to cancer I don't know
Thank You chair I'm supporting councilor
Perry on this because parking in Church
Street is a nightmare and when I attend
classes at the church hall off from his
overflow so to encourage any more
parking I think would lead to the
problems that was clearly out lated
lined by calipari and by the parish
council so I went begin with the
officers recommendation so we've had one
proposal from cancer brain cancer
fielding I'm against put doing away with
the car parking at the top end there is
this so so I'm not we I'm not with
counselor brain I suppose I'm with
Chancellor Perry so this is left to meet
a second a proposal or to go with the
three members of the committee it's a
very
balance one in my opinion and I'm still
reluctant me still minded to support
catch the brain so well second his
proposal and we will go to the vote see
can we just clarify the application
it's obviously walkway so some
landscaping works and the the Alba and
the removal of the car parking spaces
I'm not which aspects you have whether
the objection is to to the scheme per se
or whether it's specifically to the loss
of the car parking spaces think we
should go to the vote and then if the
votes defeated we would then us for the
counter proposal and with the plan and
reasons for refusal from from the people
so all those in favor of cancer brains
proposal to grant the application to
chairman all those against three
Chairman the the vote is asked
we were now looking for an alternative
proposal to the one that's just been
lost so cats the fielding proposed that
the we do away with the Arbor we leave
the parking spaces that were there
originally and I'm quite in favor of
using that back entrance it's just the
car parking space at the the top end of
the in the car parking area so yeah can
you just firm that police but our policy
refusal when my my refusal my comment or
refusal is that we should shouldn't do
away with the car parking we shouldn't
do have the Arbor there or if it is
going to be there it's outside the car
parking and therefore we'll just see
what currents got for a pond and reason
for I can see what sorry
say if members concerns are with the the
Arbor and the loss of the car parking
spaces if you're minded you could
include a separate condition to say
something along the lines of
notwithstanding approved plans no
permission is granted for the Arbor and
that areas will remain free for car
parking and then you can grant consent
for the other works if you have no
objections to those I'm happy with that
myself
continue so yeah I think really we need
to there are you prepared to come with
it I'm prepared I'm not prepared to go
along with counseling suggestion but
what we'd normally do is we would sit
around the table and think of reasons
for refusal and we have got to a clean
sheet again you put a you put a motion
forward it fails we're back to square
one that's where we go okay we're not
approving or refusing because we went
for a promote that was put down
it doesn't mean we've refused it full
stop go back to a clean sheet okay all
right I will second cancer Fielding's
proposal on the basis to get this doubt
with bearing in mind what the officer
said that we can condition it every
condition and use the planning reasons
seeking you just just so we're clear if
I so we know what we're voting on cancer
can you clarify that cancer brain but to
take the Arbor a to keep the parking
spaces in suture the planning officer
then gave us the planning reason what we
could use you're happy about cancer
feeling the planning reason was I just
be could you just just so we're 100%
clear on this one so you could condition
out the removal of both sorry you could
condition out the removal of that
element from the scheme with a condition
and the the reason would be in the
interest of highway safety and amenity
yeah I'm parking provision CS 26 so
we'll just make sure again we're clear
the hey will so the same number of
parking spaces that exists now will
still exist so the the scheme that was
previously approved under the earlier
application that we considered tonight
resulted in the loss of one car parking
space or two car parking spaces sorry
and an additional disabled space to this
area over here so that's already been
approved and so this scheme of C results
results in the loss of that entire row
of car parking along here but as as
approved under the previous scheme
there's there's three car parking spaces
in our location that can remain so are
we clear on that now we've had a
proposal and the seconder
so we were going to the vote pathway
with the condition with this condition
added condition in will he be able to
achieve his new leg for his pathway
so these two-car parking spaces were
shown removed on the plans that we've
already approved tonight so this part of
the scheme if you don't approve this
element won't impact that part of
proposed on a second all those in favor
fortune against lawn chair committee
resolves to grant application 18 / 0 2 2
4 2 ful in line with realized recommend
conditions all right thank you for that
we can have a five-minute break after
that one and thank you for bearing with
us on that one
thank you thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen sorry we're so short right
there with complex applications and we
were clogged in so we'll now move on to
our next item which is 18 slash is their
node two five one three fu out which is
first field Dan skirt ship step on on
stellar we move all the permanent
Carnarvon erection of a single Gerling
and it's Matthew Stern again Thank You
chairman the application site relates to
pasture land situated between Blackwell
and Dallas course indicated by the black
dot in the center of the screen okay so
the the applicant application site
itself ashamed by the red line is notice
two buildings no conservation areas and
the site itself currently contains one
caravan but it does have an existing a
certificate of lawfulness for existing
use for two caravans on the sonic which
I'm sure will be discussed tonight so
the application site itself is indicated
by the red arrow you can see this sort
of the open countryside location that
it's situated within the access itself
is situated from this point here and
leads north up to the to the caravan
that sighted there at the moment this is
the access looking back towards the
roads are looking southwards and then
this is the access looking northwards
towards whether the caravan site is so
this is the existing caravan on the site
the certificate of lawfulness that's
been granted on the site is pretty much
delineated by that post and rail fence
that you can see sort of in the
foreground leading towards the left-hand
side of the screen over there so this is
some views of looking northwards and
then looking westwards there's an
existing barn situated just to the west
of the application sorry so the proposed
development is for a new bungalow
situated on the same plot of land so yes
sorry it's designed in a t-shape
approximately in the same location as
the sighting it is this thing caravan so
that that's the proposed elevations it's
gable fronted towards the the parking
area at the south of the property and
then hips on the other roofs there's
also sort of a gap in the middle of the
built form there and then there's a sort
of a CGI image of the bit of the
proposed building there so there's a
detailed assessment in the agenda
signing on page 65 there's in summary
there's two main issues whether the
principle of development is acceptable
in this location and whether the harm to
the sorry whether there's harm to the
visual character of the landscape so the
applications recommended for refusal for
two reasons
and they're set out on page 89 a few
committee report thank you Thank You
Matthew first peak which is councillor
Rob heat from Edgington price council
and thank you for bearing with us mr.
Heath again you've got three minutes
would you like warning with 30 seconds
to go oh yes please thank you thank you
okay thank you
I just like to confirm before we set out
that the owner of the site has consulted
with the Parish Council and also the
community have met and invited the owner
of the site and the Parish Council to
attend a community lead meeting so a lot
of these points have come out of the
back of that kind of community led
meeting in the support for this
application we're concerned that the
description of the development is a bit
misleading the site has a certificate of
law lawfulness for two caravans for
permanent residential use that could
mean two families living on the site for
time consider the intensification of use
was the planners might not want to
accept this some intents of Gason of use
without and the need for planning
permission is possible with court
judgments and appeal decisions point to
the fact that something
intensification of use would probably
not require planning permission that
would very probably be the case for one
or more caravans our community concerns
are that travellers and this was their
kind of the issue with this site before
if planning application is made for
temporary traveller pitches the current
national guidance is that the absence of
a five-year supplied to meet the need is
a special material consideration when
determining such application this makes
it difficult to justify refusal of such
applications temporary emissions turn
into permanent permissions so the
fallback position the application is for
one house which will supplant a lawful
use for at least two or very probably
three caravans in a permanent
residential use and probably more in
terms of essential use there is very
significant gain is substituting one
small house for three or more
potentially occupied permanently by
separate families the site is remote
from all local services the road which
is used by lots of the local community
is a single track road with very little
traffic at present so conditions
thinking about conditions the planning
authority has no means which to secure
landscape improvements impose any other
restrictions on the size of present the
existing caravan of sight is visible
from the road and what as will be any
additional caravans the proposed
bungalow would be visible but there
would be an opportunity to impose
conditions and landscaping provisions
but it would also enable the planning
authority to gain control over what
happens on this site if approved the
house should supplant the caravan use
local support for this proposal goes
back to the time when it was purchased
to avoid it becoming an unauthorised
caravan site occupied by travellers
support for the application is based on
the assumption that the planning
permission of her house would supplant
the existing caravan uses lines we ask
that the committee takes this
opportunity to secure the future of this
site and look to support the application
thank you
[Music]
No
I was very good good thank you thank you
thank you very much
how about our next speaker which is
Hattie slide
hello hi again you've got three minutes
and if you want taller keep the warning
with 30 seconds to go that's okay far
away
good evening the application site was
bought by the estate in 2009 at the
request of local people who were
concerned given the pressure for
traveler sites in the area and its
history of Caravan use that it would
become another unauthorized traveler
site the estate now seeks to replace the
existing caravan with a permanent
dwelling something inspectors have
allowed on appeal in similar
circumstances your case officer
identifies two concerns the impact on
the countryside and sustainability so
firstly sustainability your policies
seek to direct new housing to towns and
larger villages to limit traffic
movements in rural locations first field
is beyond any settlement but is already
in residential use it accommodates a
permanent residential caravan and could
lawfully accommodate two such caravans
so two families the proposal will not
therefore create a new residential use
moreover the proposal will not result in
any increase in traffic on rural roads
there's no difference between a family
living in a caravan and one living in a
bungalow there'd only be one bungalow
and one family but there could be two
caravans and two families secondly the
impact on the countryside there's a
maximum statutory size for a caravan 20
meters by six point eight meters 136
square metres the caravan at first field
is smaller than that but could be
increased to the maximum size without
need for any further planning permission
indeed there could be two such caravans
caravans are rectangular blocks with
flat roofs are usually white and
generally unattractive they stick out in
the countryside and are visible from
great distances and it's against this
that the current application must be
considered the proposed bungalow has a
footprint which is less than the maximum
size of one Caravan it's been designed
with reference to other nearby
properties has a low ridge height and is
finished with locally sourced materials
it's an attractive property and your
case officer concludes it to be
acceptable from a design perspective its
impact on the landscape will be less
significant and more desirable than even
one maximum size caravan yes it would be
a permanent structure rather than a
caravan which can look transient but as
you've heard there have been caravans on
this site for decades that is not going
to change here is the chance to remove
the unattractive caravans and put up a
single well-designed bungalow your core
strategy states that where a proposal is
not covered by a specific policy
permission should be granted where it is
fully justified offers significant
benefits to the local area and is not
contrary to the overall development
strategy
this proposal complies with these
criteria of a single bungalow is just as
sustainable as the existing caravan the
proposed bungalow is properly designed
and will enhance the character of
appearance of the area and it will
remove the threat of unauthorized
occupation and expansion
moreover the development has the support
as you've heard of the parish councils
mr. snow please finish your sentence the
proposal is policy compliant and I ask
that you support the application and
grant plan permission
you said that the land was built bought
by the estate is this going to be a
state workers cottage or was he going to
be built and then sold off it's not
decided whether it would be an estate
workers cottage we have read that
decision hasn't been made yet
yes I don't think to clarify I think
he's just going to be an herb the market
property is gonna be no conditions on on
who can live there and it's it can be an
open market and be sold in the normal
principle normal way not to somebody
who's got a link to the village so it's
just I think I think you I think it was
the terminology estate I think that
cancel accordion was unsure of but I
think we've think that's right is that
right this come in open market property
yes there's nothing in the report it
says there's a local condition so that's
the pairing German it's come to my
notice that this is the applicant is
Compton scorpion estate which through my
work I have an association with so I
wasn't aware of it at the time but I'm
going to need to sit down from the
Committee on this application
didn't know
unfortunately we're gonna have to until
next time
we're just checking whether we can find
a substitute yet no no no problem
so we'll just check on whether castle so
we'll have a short recess to see whether
counselor kettle would be able to
substitute on this item and there's that
way we wouldn't have to defer but we
need to take some advice before we can
do that
can go wrong has gone wrong tonight so
apologies for July and everybody making
them stay here longer but we need to
make sure we get this right and I'd
rather just have a short recess before
we get the make the wrong decision
chairman we could offer him a cup of
coffee or a glass of water because I've
been waiting for so long yeah so if
anybody just just need to go and get a
drink here that is the coffee machine
outside here as well
I bow please
Yeah right could you go to that one
first
we just need to clarify yes please yeah
the change in the Constitution means
that we can have substitute members
right so that's fine and the fact that
you've met the training requirements in
your up-to-date reach on your nose only
slight concerned and it was that you
weren't actually sat at the table for
the application but you were in the back
of the room and obviously we've had the
presentation and we've had a speaker a
couple of speakers already are you happy
and willing to continue and are you did
you hear everything that was said by the
presenting officer and the speakers so
if you can give us that assurance that
you're happy that you're fully
understand what's gone on so far I think
we'll be able to allow you to sit at B
yeah but it's your judgement well
clearly I heard both presentations from
I'm not sure I caught the early bit of
Matthew's presentation okay we'll we'll
have to restart so we'll restart with
the application will ask to the parish
council to do his bit again and then the
application applicant again so sorry
about that so we have to rewind and
worry about a substitute for the rest of
the meeting
can you substitute for the rest of the
meeting you can take yourself out as
ward member on the last item thank you
right then deja vu or mafia part two no
Matthew sorry about this there we go
okay so the sorry let me just find the
notes so the application site relates to
a passive line between Blackwell and
Darla's Scot it's indicated by the black
line at black dot sorry in the center of
the screen just there so the application
site is found by the red line and
there's an existing access off of the
road here the site isn't within a
conservation area and there's no listed
buildings the site currently is occupied
by one Caravan although there is a
certificate of lawfulness for two
caravans which you'll hear about later
the application site is shown there by
the red arrow indicating this site and
it's open countryside location the
existing access is off this point here
and lead to north up to the caravan
which is sighted there this is the
access looking southwards back towards
the road
and it's currently gated at that point
so this is looking north up towards
where the caravan is sited and the the
track that leads to it this is looking
sort of in a northeasterly direction
towards the existing caravan that
situated on the plot of land and the
certificate of lawfulness pretty much
follows that you post a rail fence that
is in the foreground just there so this
view is looking north across the fields
and again this is looking west there's a
gate into the agricultural land adjacent
and there's a barn just in the centre
behind the trailer so the proposed
development relates to the construction
of a new dwelling in the form of a
bungalow it's in a t-shape these are the
proposed elevations the the gable at the
top there that fronts the parking area
to the south of the property
and then there another a number of other
hit trees across the building and then
that's the CGI image of the proposed
awning there's a couple of updates on
the update she just some additional
comments from the parish council and the
third-party the applications recommended
for fees or for two reasons and their
sound and the agenda for you thank you
thank you my thing move on to our first
speaker which is councillor Rob heat
I'll try okay okay so to kind of confirm
from the outset the owners of the site
have consulted with the parish council
and the local community have also got
together and organized a meeting
themselves inviting the owner of the
site and the parish council to attend to
discuss the the this planning
application so I'm kind of representing
the views of the parish council taken
into account the meeting I attended and
I heard of the local community we're
concerned that the description of the
development is a bit misleading the site
has a certificate of lawfulness for two
caravans for permanent resident
residential use that could mean two
families living on the site full-time
consider the intensification of use
whilst the planners might not want to
accept that some intensification of use
without the need for Planning Commission
is possible the court judgments and
appeal decisions point to the fact that
some intensification of use would
probably not require planning permission
that would very probably be the case for
want more caravan and possibly more
community concerns or for the travelers
if a planning application is made for
temporary traveler pitches the current
national guidance is that the absence of
a five year supply to meet the need is a
special material consideration when
determining such applications this makes
it difficult to justify refusal of such
applications temporary permissions turn
into permanent
missions so the fallback position the
application is for one house which will
supplant a lawful use for at least two
and very probably three caravans in a
permanent residential use and possibly
more in terms of sustainable sustainable
use there is a very significant gain in
substitute in one small house for
possibly three caravans each potentially
occupied by separate families there will
be very significant gain in reduced car
journeys the site is remote from all
services and the road is used by many
locals as a local dog walking and scenic
walk conditions the planning authority
has no means by which to secure
landscape improvements and impose any
other restrictions as it is the existing
caravan is a visible from the road as
would any additional caravans be visible
the proposed bungalow will be visible
but there would be an opportunity to
impose a landscaping condition and other
conditions such as removing permitted
development rights conditions will
enable the planning authority to gain
control over what happens on the site if
approved the house should supplant the
caravan use local support for this
proposal goes back to the time it's
purchased to avoid it becoming an
authorized and unauthorized caravan site
30 seconds occupied by travellers
support for the application is based on
the assumption that the planning
permission for a house stroke bungalow
which the planning application is would
supplant the existing caravan use rights
we ask that the committee take or use
this opportunity to secure the future of
this site and look to support the
application and the local community
thank you
any questions for price counselor
No thank you very much you can move on
to our applicant which is Hattie
something this light right three minutes
will give you a warning within 30
seconds thank you the application site
was bought by the estate in 2009 at the
request of local people who were
concerned given the pressure for
traveler sites in the area and its
history of Caravan use that it would
become another unauthorized traveler
site the estate now seeks to replace the
existing caravan with a permanent
dwelling something inspectors have
allowed on appeal in similar
circumstances your case offer identifies
two concerns the impacts on the
countryside and sustainability so
firstly sustainability your policies
seek just directly housing to towns and
larger villages to limit traffic
movements in rural location first field
is beyond any settlement but is already
in residential use it accommodates a
permanent residential caravan and could
lawfully accommodate two such caravans
so two families the proposal will not
therefore create a new residential use
moreover the proposal will not result in
any increase in traffic on rural roads
there's no difference between a family
living in a caravan and one living in a
bungalow there would be only one
bungalow and one family but there could
be two caravans and two families
secondly the impact on the countryside
there is a maximum statutory size for a
caravan twenty by six point eight meters
136 square metres the caravan at first
field is smaller than that but could be
increased to the maximum size without
need for any further planning permission
indeed there could be two such caravans
caravans are rectangular blocks with
flat roofs and usually white are
generally unattractive they stick out in
the countryside and are visible from
great distances and it is against this
that the current application must be
considered the proposed bungalow has a
footprint which is less than the maximum
size
one caravan it's been designed with
reference to other nearby properties has
a low ridge height and is finished with
locally sourced materials it's an
attractive property and your case
officer concludes it to be acceptable
from a design perspective its impact on
the landscape will be less significant
and more desirable than even one maximum
sized caravan yes it would be a
permanent structure rather than a
caravan which can look transient but as
you've heard there have been caravans on
this site for decades that is not going
to change here is the chance to remove
unattractive caravans and put up a
single well-designed bungalow your core
strategy states that where a proposal is
not covered by a specific policy
Planning Commission should be granted
where it is fully justified offers
significant benefits to the local area
and shown on contrary to the overall
development strategy this proposal
complies with all these criteria a
single bungalow is just as sustainable
as the existing Caravan resulting no
increase in traffic the proposed
bungalows properly designed and will
enhance the character and appearance of
the area and it will remove the threat
of unauthorized occupation and expansion
moreover the development has the support
of the parish council the district
councillor and a large number of local
residents overall the proposal is
compliant and I ask that you support the
application and grant planning
permission thanks very much you you say
that you the estate bought the land in
their owner Oh 9 who owned it before
that was it park because you said the
village asked your the local residents
asked you was it one that was empty or
that's probably relevant to this again I
think we've touched on it earlier so I
think that's really irrelevant or could
you could you expand your question then
because what I'm trying to guess the
question I asked earlier on is it is
being bought by the estate and therefore
is the use of this going to be for
state worker or is it going to be on the
other market now that is a better
question
so how happy fees under that it was
thought it was going up it had been
occupied by a lady who'd deceased and
the the site was going up for a sale by
auction at the moment it has a tenant
living in the caravan who is not an
estate worker any further questions to
Brian to the site in way of electricity
sewage etc currently it has mains water
and septic tank
solar power and a wind turbine not
currently but we have taken we've
obtained quotes and is we've had a
feasibility study done and it is quite
easy to do thank you thank you any
further questions thank you very much
you're you're free to go
then we have our next speaker which is
catch the st. our Ward number
so I'd be waiting forever there but
there by now I've got five minutes
against the site thank you I want to
tackle this application from the point
of view of location but before I do that
accounts Lipari is right
the state is Compton scorpion estates
and mr. Knight the applicant does live
at Compton scorpion Manor and he's
well-known to me in that in that in that
context and I think we have to believe
what has he just told us about the
circumstances about but he became
involved in his purchase because there
was an old lady that lived there I can
remember as I said last week at Council
my 20 years as those local member had
come up he's has now passed last week or
earlier this week and it was one of
these things in intellectual register
that we had great difficulty with at one
time but eventually we located it and
there was an old lady that lived there
almost as a hermit and when she died so
whoever owned the land was trying to
sell it and effectively the local
traveler community was taking a vast
interest and that is what motivates him
mr. Knight to buy the site and as I said
in the declaration of interest about
three hours ago I'd had a conversation
with him only last weekend he rang me
and he reaffirmed that concern but
effectively he would act as the local
philanthropist and ensure that
effectively that site was not at risk
from travelers and we have to remember
less than a mile away there is a major
traveler site and when that was occupied
this council got very excited and said
how they were going to control it and
how they were going to get rid of these
and they're still there and that was
about 2008 as well and the reason
they're still there is because they've
got planning permission on appeal
and there's a high high high risk of
that happening at this site from what I
can gather mr. Knight has got to the
stage where he might sell the property
and we have to look at it whether we
sell it and I see mesas looking
disgusted at you he wants to sense you
what I'm going to say again but the
issue was that just do do we actually
grant planning permission and allow him
to sell it with a property on there or
do we effectively allow him to sell it
as a caravan site in which case we know
from the local communities that the
local traveler communities will be there
this doesn't seem to concern the
planning manager I asked the question to
earlier on this evening but effectively
I think it should do I stopped chairman
while the I just wanted you to pay
attention to what I was saying this
listens our mayor right now the
situation is if we go back to Matthews
original thing where the black blob was
is this particular proposal that far
from the local communities he's
described as being part of darling scope
but he's much nearer to blackwell and
the local ships turned North Ward that I
represent does have a number of Hamlet's
in that area that have been developed as
part of trilliant in parish over many
many years and therefore we've got
examples of the the old railway station
at London Road which is on the other
side of darlings good now that is
equidistant from a civilization as to
what this proposal is yet we've allowed
a massive great big housing development
there on what was just a signalers
cottage at a junction and therefore this
particular location it might look remote
from there and I'm not quite sure the
orientation of everything on that
particular
aerial picture but the situation is
quite simple this house is not stuck on
to a village or a hamlet
there is a gap the space between it and
the surrounding countryside but
effectively it's not that far out and
there are many other examples are
buildings that have been that far from
communities which have had approval 30
seconds right so consequently I think we
dismiss that objection that's my wish
that the committee does and effectively
takes seriously the risk that we've got
of having a second traveller site in my
ward which I don't want had enough
problems with the first one and we've
proved incapable of controlling it and
mr. Heath referred to it too why and
what the wife is were so consequently I
do implore you to grant this please
unless settle at this site for good
we don't have an old lady in a hermit
anymore we have a city a real live
situation where that site is at risk
Thank You counsel
you referred to the elderly lady who
lived on this site did she live in what
had previously could have been described
as a habitation always in a barn that
she was camping no I think it was a
caravan yeah but there was referral to a
building here before the caravans
arrived I'm trying to establish becomes
a saint with the lady lived in that
building and therefore was it something
that's fallen down that was previously a
house I'm not sure I can answer that
question chairman I just don't know the
answer as far as I'm aware the lady that
used to live there in first field lived
in a caravan
so I could give you
No thank you very much gates of riot I
know he's from Trenton Parish Council
spoke to a snog it's all part of trading
from parish there is one parish council
which covers all these little
communities oh I see
well I thought you knew the answer as
well well never mind
you asked the question so I've answered
you Thank You councillor Saint move on
to points of clarification yeah it's
slightly to sangil but you might expect
that first mr. chairman from my previous
saddle this committee before there's
reference to the building which I just
asked asked council st. about if that
had been an agricultural bomb it would
have been permissible to convert that to
a house under development legal detail
of it would be so there are permitted
development development rights for barn
conversions it has to meet a set
criteria and without a building there
and without an application we can't
assess that or give way to that there
are no buildings on the site at the
moment I think when the there was an
earlier planning application I think
that's in your agenda that was withdrawn
at that time I think in 2013 there were
some dilapidated agricultural buildings
in this sort of area of the site but
they were subsequently removed so they
wouldn't benefit from permitting rights
for those
there's currently a very large
development my ward of the US Mint works
which have been inaudible since 1994 I
think and partly been flattened for an
extensive period of time and that's
described as a brownfield site could
this therefore on the same criteria that
relates to that application which the
planning manager might be aware of
could this be described as a brownfield
site but by the existence of previous
constructed form no I don't believe it
would the relates to use of land from
what I understand the the buildings were
possibly associated with the occupancy
yo-yo committee of the of the caravan
there were two caravans on the site I
think one of the caravans the side was
completely off of it and there were some
some barns I don't know the exactly use
of those but I believe they were
agricultural by looking at the
photographs from the site at that time I
don't have those photos with me tonight
I'm afraid right so we established the
wearing of colorful buildings and can
that be defined as no concrete no in
agricultural buildings are within their
own classification gone cancer field
if we were to grant could we put a
condition on this for local needs use
that that's not what's been applied for
so the assessment that we're making at
the moment is without that condition I'm
tying it sort of couple the points the
price counts them mentioned about
intensification of use more caravans can
be put on the site by Planning
Commission cases of like in the past
presidents or I personally don't know if
any Ben some considerable distribution
around this particular topic the view
this is limited to two to two caravans
because of the lawful development
certificate super a second question is
that we're only looking at the
application as it stands before us
there's no fallback position and we can
only decide what's in front of us so the
issues regarding whether it could be
sold as a traveler side or bought and
then the uses travel site hypertunnel to
stuff to this application I think at the
moment that the use of those two
caravans isn't restricted to any
particular person so if somebody did
want to buy the site and occupy it for
those purposes then they could do so I
suppose there's there's nothing to stop
planning permission being granted and
then the site subs currently even bought
for that purpose and planning permission
so at that time but yeah the the the
application before use for the dwelling
I think Jo we do need to clarify that
position though
in terms of the lawful development
certificate relates to to permanent to
permanent residential use
so the caribou occupation traveler
traveler and gypsy site would therefore
to be for that type of occupancy it
would have to it would have to be
permanent occupation so I think we're
not we it wouldn't fall in my view it
wouldn't fall within the position that
office development certificate wouldn't
then allow scope for travelers moving in
and out of the site so we would
effectively I think be talking about
settled travelers in terms of this
certificate i would also i think i
should clarify that but obviously the
the consideration around alternative
occupies of the site is equally
pertinent to any other any other site
and is wholly within the remit of the
landowner to determine who is site it
might be sold to from our point of view
we are looking at this strictly in
relation to policies as set out in the
refusal reasons in the report and one
small slight one page 69 third-party
responses nineteen letters were received
three letters of objection 15 that it is
a support i assume the other one neither
supported or objected yeah i think they
raised comments on on the proposal i
think they were asking for clarity over
the proposals rather than necessarily
objecting or supporting the application
it's not about that right so now move on
to counsel cattle are you've got another
point of clarification if we get away as
10a s10 supports small-scale schemes for
housing employment or community
facilities both under the community
heading and under
central would you define this as small
scale in terms of our core strategy
page 192 Soviet in in terms of the
proposals they would they would amount
to a small scale being a single dwelling
the the bit that you're looking at there
is the community LED schemes this isn't
a community LED scheme
it's a open market dwelling essentially
so you'd be looking at more point B
within the policy or possibly whilst I
accept is just an exceptional quality
InDesign covered under J where it's
making a positive contribution to the
character local area if the argument is
that this is of a better design than the
caravan would that be reasonable
argument policy J relates to the what
were power 55 now para seventy-nine
houses so they're the innovative and
exceptional quality houses I would argue
that this is probably neither of those
there are other exceptions within the
policy such as a permanent dwelling for
occupation of a person engaged in
agricultural enterprises but again they
haven't applied for this and they
haven't provided that justification
today I'm not arguing that I'm arguing
purely under you you talk about NP P
paragraph 55 and you say exceptional
that is not actually a complete
description of paragraph 55 which
requires of very good or exceptional I
think if Planning Manager brings out Pat
roughly two five there is a an or not an
and
so what was power 55 is now power of 79
and the point you're referring to is I
read it to you the design is of
exceptional quality in that it is truly
outstanding or innovative reflecting the
highest standards in architecture and
would help the raise the standards of
design more generally in rural areas and
would significantly enhance its
immediate settings and be sensitive to
the defining characteristics of the
local area yes so good design it doesn't
have to be something wacky no it does
need to be exceptional design the the
the bar that's set for wood what would
the power of 55s is a very very high bar
as a consequence
very few applications will meet that bar
and the intention at the outset for
thought for the power of 55 houses was
to be the the next generation of
exceptional houses in own countryside in
conflict with normal policies to
restrain restrain residential different
indiscriminate residential development
in the countryside the application
certainly hasn't been assessed under
this and it wouldn't it wouldn't meet
that test in my opinion the Ryan
Chairman I think the officers got the
recommendation of rice but in saying out
I think it's a finely balanced decision
that we need to make we're looking at
open countryside location and the
validation control zone which is way far
away from the body so we need to look at
the open countryside location if anybody
knows this line and I know it pretty
well
it links darlings cook to Blackwell and
just adjacent to the site it's an old
Dutch barn so we have to consider the
arm to the look the open countryside
I think Nam is already there well the
use of the caravan that's been there for
years with the potential of another
Caravan that and some so on balance I
could go with the applicant on this and
not the officers yes it's it's an open
source outside of the built-up boundary
it's our mom looking up I don't think
it's cause considerable arm for what's
there already
I'm actually an agreement with counts to
brain and whilst it's not exceptional
design as we've established is it still
looks a lot better than the caravan
that's there and we'll give you some
control over the landscaping etc so I
will actually be going against
recommendation and looking to support
the applicant on this one and the member
little looking at the officers
recommendation there are two reasons one
of which is say 15 16 and the other is
the the open side and we might have
mentioned the built a very boundary now
we know full well
built up there about us have not yet
been adopted by this council they
haven't been even gone through cabinets
at this stage and therefore they carry
very little weight an argument which I
have proposed free on previous occasions
I'm very much against open countryside
development but the built-up area
rebounder is not one which I believe can
be used in this case it has not been
adopted by this council and as I
mentioned when I last up from the
committee in June and July and inspector
overturned decisions and said that the
vua be carried very little weight in
stock for district we have to bear that
in mind
so we then go on to the other policies
that are mentioned and if we go through
the list of policies have mentioned on
page 66 and remember planning is a
balance and to avoid harm where the
benefit is over idea but if we look at
this one its sustainable development
there's already a president of
residential sites there climate change I
suspect this will be an enhancement on
the existing and I know the wedding it
is not but the accommodation for want of
a better word so therefore it's just see
it comply the cs2 cs3 landscape I
believe this property will be an
enhancement on the current impact on the
landscape of the caravans and design
distinct business it's a reasonable
design I think the officers acknowledge
there's nothing wrong with the design so
and I could go on through 14 20 25 26
and is 10 and they would all be inclined
towards supporting it so if we look at
the planning balance there's
overwhelming policies and support of
this if we were to accept the planning
officers contention that this is falls
fallow verse 10 now despite the planning
manager's comments on NPP a paragraph 55
my reading reiatives is considerably
different to yours I'm sorry but there
is ample room for good quality design it
doesn't have to be something out of the
latest version of docto it's got to be
good really good now this may not be
really good but I don't think I think
paragraph 35 and our supporting policies
do allow good quality buildings to be
built in the countryside they don't have
to be so dramatic that they win prizes
from whoever give prizes to these things
so be UAB I'm sorry it doesn't count
anyway the vast majority of policies are
in support so I'm in accordance with my
throughout the colleagues this is an
acceptable application with very little
harm going along with what councillor
kettle was referring to with regards to
the building's old buildings that were
on that site I can't help but feel that
they were probably agricultural I know
there's no concrete down there but they
were probably built when before concrete
was sort of laid on in agricultural
buildings
therefore my feeling is it's very much a
brownfield site and also with the with
the caravans being settled there it has
the same to my mind and same weight that
it is a redundant site and therefore
should be developed very briefly I don't
think it is a brownfield site disagree I
tend to disagree with cats the kettle on
the n-double PF 55 stroke 79 and I don't
think it qualifies I think it's it's
good but it's okay I don't think it's
exceptional so that were the points I
would disagree with I do agree with lot
of the other points that have been
raised but I we've gone round quite a
bit on looking for some need to come up
with a proposal
as I started I think I can propose that
we go with the applicants proposal for
not refusal but for grant on the basis
that it is a sustainable location its
second counselor brains proposal but I
would add that I accept the points on MP
MPP f55 I've got a lot of time on that
policy and I believe I know it quite
well but I'll rest on that one but I
believe that the balance of the policies
listed in the application on page 66 and
67 are in meat this app this application
meets those policies and it's not we do
not have a built-up area bound around
this village at this current marked time
and therefore that cannot be used as an
argument to refuse this application okay
so brain thank you and also Curran can
you just reasons the reason is there's
not enough reasons from the planning
point of view
okay so I have produced a draft list of
conditions these have been circulated
with the African sage and they've been
agreed so I'll quickly run through them
so there's a time limit condition
there's a plans condition there's land
contamination assessments and
remediation work suss conditions three
and four they were American recommended
by the environments of a health officer
then there's highways condition about
upgrading the access into the site
there's condition 6 will be parking and
maneuvering within the site condition 7
details of the boundary enclosures to be
submitted to us for approval condition 8
is that the drawings not occupied until
it's fitted with water puts onto the
town pipes condition 9 is providing the
cabling for electric vehicle charging
points 10 is provision of bins 11 is
removal of permitted development rights
for extensions classes 8 we site
includes outbuildings and a condition
restricting use of any of the land
within the red line so that it's not use
for the site and you're happy to agree
any additions from no casketball
once they're nice a point yeah I've got
one could just just in terms of this
caravan restriction there's currently a
north of development certificate for the
use of this site by caravans by two
caravans you say the rest of the land
could be can be restricted but can that
certificate to allow two caravans
on the built up basic can that LDC be
removed as a condition so that there is
no there's no right to permanently park
any caravan at any positive side I
believe we could deal with that by way
of a condition restricting that use so
that the certificate of lawfulness
granted the the siting of two caravans
in that area there and the garden being
that area so that they wouldn't be able
to cite the caravans up in that northern
section anyway but I believe we can deal
with the rest of it by way of condition
that previous mission by certificate is
is removed so there can be no
opportunity in the future for caravans
to come back on the site using a
historic so I mean it's in the
application in anyway just
double-checking so on that condition
we're happy to delegate that to officers
so yeah so Curran or mafia could come up
with the reasons reasons to accept yes
according with the the discussion from
members suggesting reason is the site is
sustainably located and the replacement
of a long-standing residential care
Caravan use on the site would cause no
significant harm to the landscape
and it proposed and castle kettle ii
suppose in the second to
all those in favor unanimous chairman
can we see resolves to grant application
eighteen it / zero two five one three fe
well Thank You Matthew
now let's move on then move on to next
item which is 18 / 0 to 1 to double to
Fe well oh yeah catch the kettle you can
be catch the Barnes if you want so 18 /
0 to 1 to 2 ful under Jason to parks
house church and price Hardwick
construction of the detached ring with
separate carport for two vehicles and
new vehicle access and thank you share
the application out for members for the
construction of a detached dwelling with
separate carport a new vehicle access
the principle the principle of
development for the site has already
been established through a previous
application which was allowed on appeal
back in December 2015 for a two-story
dwelling with access the application
site is identified by the black bar and
is situated on the village edge of
priors Hardwick the application site is
outlined here in red the site occupies a
corner pappas the
Sharon its eastern and southern
boundaries with the village Conservation
Area there's also a public footpath
running to the south of the site today
we've got an aerial photo which
demonstrates the relationship between
the site and the surrounding pattern of
development and this slide here just
shows the existing site layout the site
covers around naught point naught 8
hectares of land and is surrounded on
its northern and southern sides by trees
so this slide here just shows the
existing extant permission for the site
so it's for a detached two-story
dwelling with three bedrooms with access
to the north similar to what's proposed
with the current application in terms of
its access overall footprint 184 square
metres over both floors as you can see
the dwelling would be centrally located
within the plot and aligned with the
neighboring dwelling jinora's which is
to the west of the site it'd be
constructed of stone beneath a slate
tile roof and there's currently an
application being processed at the
minute did discharge the conditions for
it so here we've got the proposed site
layout of the application currently
before you
it's a u-shaped footprint and it will be
facing towards parks house to the east
again we've got the access to the north
which would lead to a detached carport
for two cars and the overall footprint
would be 480 square metres over both
floors so this slide here just shows the
proposed front and rear elevations and
this slide here is showing the side
elevations so facing north it should be
east and west you can also see the
carport in these plans and here as well
we've got some proposed sections of the
site so that's the site facing towards
the rear courtyard so floor plans the
dwelling would provide three bedrooms at
first one level and one on the
ground-floor and now just turning to
images of the application site
so this photo here is taken east of the
site from church and so it's facing into
this light there and you can see the
neighboring properties Chinchin aries
just beyond so this photo is is taken
from a similar location but panning
slightly to the left facing towards the
bend of the road of church and you can
see two Nerys again in the background
this photo here is taken from church and
again to the side you can just see the
road been in towards Aunt Mary's clothes
and you can see the access towards the
houses access from church and and here
we've got a photo showing the front
elevations of sceneries and green acres
and so this is generis this Green Acres
and the site is here donated denoted by
the blue arrow and this photo is taken
from within the application site facing
towards parks house and here we've just
got some final panoramic photos the top
one just shows the site in its full
context extent and the bottom photo here
is taken from Welsh Road facing to water
church and you've got parks house air
this site would be just there so in
terms of updates the report did
incorrectly reference the date the
comments will receive from the parish
council which has now been amended on
the update sheet and chairman it's
recommended to refuse the application
for the reason set out on the report
which can be found on page 89 of the
agenda mr. Steve Adams
Thank You mr. chairman of the prize
Hardwick parish meeting wasn't able to
be here so asked me to read out their
statement okay thanks very much we we
the village support the change in siting
design and external materials applied
for mr. mrs. James discussed the new
plan with their neighbors living at the
chenery's before they applied to the
Planning Department mr. mrs. Hobday in
their letter which is displayed on the
council's website says they feel this
new design allows more light unless
overshadowing than the original
application they do have a question
regarding air-conditioning units and
secret condition be placed should you
pass this new scheme in my statement on
behalf of the village I mentioned that
the position of the dwelling changed the
street scene this is not a negative
comment rather an observation the
village has a myriad of styles and
materials used in buildings our village
plan identifies the need to be
sympathetic to the surroundings and use
natural materials to blend in with the
site mr. James has chosen a design which
is similar to parks house which is
opposite the plot and also has taken
great care in choosing matching
materials my reasons for talking about
the street scene is the village is keen
a condition is placed to ensure the
grass verge owned by a highways and
village is left natural and will when
standing at the end of st. Mary is
looking down the road appear to be one
continuous verge bar the driveway the
village would also seek and mr. James
has agreed that the pedestrian pathway
be refused the village and our councilor
Chris Williams support this application
thank you very much
any questions mr. Adams
no out cancer brain I'm slightly
confused because she referred to the
statement it's my my my I'm not the
parish council was it a unanimous
decision of the parish council or is it
one person's observation okay
the this is a statement from Candida
Kelly who's chairman of the price
Hardwick parish meeting she was speaking
on behalf of the parish meeting it's
actually a parish meeting rather than a
parish council but the but the chairman
did speak to me and she let me know that
that was her intention so it's on behalf
of source that meet but it is a meeting
not a parent council any further
questions thank you Miss Adams
oh you're free to go and I have mr.
Smith's the David Smith please
again you've got three minutes mr. Smith
the aim of the scheme mr. chairman was
to provide a large contemporary family
home that is future proof by the design
I believe that the degree of local
supporter has been expressed as an
indication the scheme is well received
and will be regarded as a visual and
Meena tea to pass Hardwick however it
seems a Planning Department objects on
two main aspects of the design the size
and the orientation with the size we
think that is because the site is at the
entrance to the village it deserves to
be of a size and character that enhances
the position wasn't being hidden away as
the exact application I believe the
design achieves this while echoing the
styles found within the village
particularly its nearest neighbor parks
house while the footprint of the house
uses quite a lot of the site the
principle of design was to provide
modern inside-out living with all the
principle spaces opening directly onto
the patio and its outside kitchen this
is in keeping with a lot of modern
designs the orientation of the house was
developed as a considered response to
the site rather than a deer into the
building lines set by the existing
nearby houses and at the same time
neatly terminates the row the wrong
boundary of the site faces parks house I
believe that should be the principal
elevation and this along with the fact
that the new vehicle access can only be
accommodated in that position shown on
dictated the design we moved it as far
away from the neighboring property to
chin areas to meet their previous
objections but at the same time stayed
within the 45 degree guidelines from
their front and rear facing windows
moving it away from the neighbor pushed
it towards the highway boundary so we
sat it on the boundary as many buildings
within the village do so we felt we
we've reinforced a principle that this
should be the Finn front elevation the
materials we máxima tears of the village
which a mix of stone slate timber lot
specific fat Foose and corrugated iron
moving
once we had the planning departments
initial response we tried to meet with
them but they were unwilling to do so so
we're here tonight hoping you'll support
the scheme questions for the agent on
two points of clarification two points
of clarification for Louise could you
just remind me of the change in size
between the original footprint yep so
the extant permission would result in an
overall footprint over both floors of
one hundred and eighty four square
meters the proposed site layout would
cover a footprint of 480 square meters
over both floors secondly the rear with
the reasons that the inspector
overturned this committee's original
refusal were so the application
originally was refused on delegated
authority because of impact on the
neighboring dwelling and also the
principle of development as well the
application was allowed on appeal given
at the time we couldn't demonstrate a
five-year housing land supply and also
the inspector concluded that the impact
on the neighboring residential property
wasn't harmful
further questions nope okeydoke we move
on to the debate you wants to start on
this and kurtal going to start on this
on I might come back mr. chairman but my
initial thoughts are we know before we
had a core strategy the inspectors were
overturning every decision this
practically this committee made and this
exceptional recently refused and
therefore had we had a call a core
strategy at the time one questions
whether in fact that the solution would
have been over tained
the first comment you made was because
we did not have a five-year housing land
supply we currently do have one and
therefore we need to look at it in that
light if we look at the size this is
such a hugely different size to what
approved by the inspector under those
rather extreme circumstances we've
previously heard I questioned whether
and we can't overturn that decision
that's been approved but this is this is
a very very different application so the
one that has been approved scale is
hugely different and when I looked at
the maps we have got that the approved
plan is in line with the existing
buildings prize Hardwick is the village
I know quite well although I don't know
this particular size there are lots of
them there are disparate buildings
between them but we have one which seems
to flow on with the existing line of the
built for the village this is a very
different design and I don't believe it
fits in with that built form and there
and that given the size I'm pretty
uncomfortable with it really
whilst I like the designs put forward my
views are inclined to go with the
offices recommendation I feel it's over
development to the site and in view of
the five-year housing land supply that
we have I think where I'm coming from is
I would have been more amenable to go
against the officers recommendation if
the design and scale of the house was
considerably smaller and more in line
with the previous appealed decision so
on the basis of over development to the
site I find myself going with the
officers recommendation on this account
I'm quite happy to propose that we go
with the officers recommendation to
refuse planning permission we've had a
proposal a second actual we go to the
vote all those in favor of refusing the
application you know mr. chairman
committee resolves to refuse application
18 / 0 - 1 - 2 Fe well before we move on
we need to resolve a little the vote
that we've had three and a half hours
and we need to vote whether we will
carry on for the next item all those in
favor that we carry on oh saying that no
it's agreed
we all agree he's carried anyway several
no move on to our final item of the
night apart from the any other business
is 18 slash does it have 1/2 hour 9 /
very The Willows top Street North End CV
47 - very condition - to permit the
construction of garages for plots 2 and
3 and to amend the design of the garage
on plot 1 include within condition 2
reference to the following door in 1615
20 G and 16 - 15 - 5 1 B and a
presenting officer is Joe Brooke thank
you chair the application saw is
situated within the village North End
and the bishops it's entombed ward as
indicated by the black dots shown on
your screen it occupies an edge of
settlement location towards the side for
the village fronting top Street turn off
and open countryside to the South there
are bungalows back in on society
Southwest and two-story dwellings -
northeast the site so sorry the site
slopes in significantly in a
northwesterly direction down towards the
public highway the site previously
comprised of dwelling known as the
Willows which you can see on your screen
- left indicated there a garage and a
combination of overgrown garden land and
dense vegetation however works have
commenced for the construction of freed
Islands an access associated garage car
park in an Associated landscape and
following the grant of Hamlet plan
information in 2017 and their
application reference 1603 - 2 0 size
for a subsequent application was
submitted in 2017 to vary the permission
and allow visibility space to be set at
prior to occupation an alternative
Wesley visibly displayed to avoid moving
to utility carbonates in line with the
plan
one eight three nine eight zero one ref
a this is granted an implant information
in 1702 one sex such a very this
variation was grant permission a new
decision was issued accordingly this
application is you can see that I layer
on your screen seeks to vary that
permission in 2017 in order to allow for
the construction of garages to serve
plot two and three as well as an
amendment that designed the permitted
garage seven plot one if you have a look
at the map you will see this is already
the permittee garage of plot one in this
location plot three is proposed to be
adjacent to it which survived see the
dwelling to the north and plot Tuesday
island where we associate it to the west
these will be two completed new garages
if planning permission is forthcoming
the applicant has provided a sectional
drawing to demonstrate Heights and
finish levels which also go into further
detail the next slide
this slide just shows the details in
heights and variations
this slide shows plot two and the
relevant and how will be set against the
applications of plot two and three and
the heights their fourth this side view
here shows how plot one and subsequent
it will be set against the plot three
buildings and north this plant here
shows what has recently been improved
under 2016 and over there four hundred
2017 variation application this is the
garage that has already been approved it
is higher and set at six meters higher
but I'll go into more detail animus
these shows the proposed East elevations
of the garages as you can now see this
is plot warms garage which is slept
three point nine five meters six meters
deep and Eve heights of 2.5 meters is
also six meters wide to be proposed as
you can see on the plan you see plot
three
we'll be subsequently enjoined and just
slightly higher due to spa graffiti the
site morning I think these are shows
good elevation joins to the North
elevation and West elevation that shows
how they relate to quite well with each
garage this is how the pots to Garrett
will propose subsidy on its own and
Jason to joining number two that is
already under construction these are the
variations between plot one's garage but
in the top side there's a photo which
shows that have already been approved
and this is the subsequent difference
which has been proposed as part of this
application these are views taken of the
proposed of them when coming in from top
streets it's hot Street stands down
there this is a drain that's under
construction the garages the plot to it
1 & 3 apologies would be set just behind
these bungalows this is an example of
dwellings that are being in the prison
built and are not part of the
consideration of this application the
garages would be set by Holland this
join in directly and also to the corner
there of a plot so this is the
application site the garages on the
throw so it would be set just to had us
the bungalows in the background not part
of the building site itself so just
there would be poor ones garrison plot
three's garage and these views of the
site come and I apologies the photos
wasn't fantastic the coming out plots to
Gary's would be set there and just the
minute is obviously no building took on
and this is the bungalows of the Willows
on the update sheet there has been a
correction regarding the relevant
summary of admin case history it was
incorrectly reference that were planning
permission for 2016 was grass on 23rd of
2018 this is corrected to planning
permission was granted 23rd 2017 officer
recommendation is for approval thanks
Jeff
thank you Jeff speaking please just
cancel Gordon coming from Burton Terrace
and uh Syd parish council and I'll bet
you're thinking at last thank you very
much three minutes okay Thank You Burton
does a parish council continue to object
to these repeated applications for this
site the developer is constantly seeking
to push the boundaries of the original
permission raising the question would
this development have been approved if
the houses and garages had all been
applied for at the same time if not then
they should not now be approved
incrementally the key issue with the
original application for five new houses
was the over development of the site
literally filling the plot with
buildings and presenting an
uninterrupted wall of buildings when
viewed from top street to the detriment
of the street view and all neighboring
properties the plans that were finally
approved for three new houses and one
garage meant that there were critical
breaks in the buildings between the
garage behind plot 1 and plot 2 and
between plot 3 and the boundary with
stone wall cottage which you could
actually see from the photos that your
planning officer just presented so yes
there if you look behind the the
building that's being built there was
the gap and you can see the bungalows
below behind and equally on the
following shot you know the me and the
following shot back one yeah you can see
between the new buildings were in the
center of the bottom photo and the
existing buildings on the left the
fragmentation of the development was
critical to mitigate its impact on the
landscape
this proposal utterly fills the
landscape literally placing new
buildings in the only two breaks in the
approved development as such the
proposal brings the development as a
whole back to the density of the first
proposal back in 2016 there was
categorically with
used by both parish and district
reducing the height of the garages does
not mitigate an over development of this
site with issues of rain water drainage
lack of green areas and the detriment to
the street scene viewed from top street
and the parish council objects to this
proposal in the strongest possible terms
thank you thank you very much sir can we
move on to our next speaker which is mr.
Bromley
three minutes when you're ready I'm sure
you know why you do know before yes
thank you chairman my clients proposals
are for modest domestic garages that
will have no harmful impact on neighbors
or the character or appearance of the
area the design uses traditional
construction materials including a brick
plinth a crane a horizontal timber
boarding for the walls with slate
covered roofs these are all materials
appropriate for a rural location though
I should say a rural village the garages
comply with the council's design
guidance for ancillary buildings The
Geysers will be subservient in scale to
the houses integrated with the layout of
the development cited in positions where
there will not be intrusive all visually
dominant the gauges will be mostly
hidden from view with very little of the
gouges visible from from top street we
note the comments of the parish council
about the density of development and the
amount of green space however it should
be noted that planning permission has
already been granted for a garage on
plot 1 which in the current scheme will
be reduced in height from 6 meters to
just under 4 meters permission has also
been granted for parking spaces in the
positions of the garages 4 plots 2 and 3
so there is already a commitment to
development for these parts of the site
the garages will not result in a
reduction of green space we also note
the comments of the parish council about
drainage however a completely new
surface water drainage system of land
drains and french drains has been
constructed which will take surface
water from the development down to the
combined sewer in top street that they
request of the planning officers we have
reduced the height of the garages they
rigidly proposed at 6 metres high
we have amended the application and now
and are now proposing the garages to be
only three point nine five metres high
a sighting and height of the garage it
is compliant with core strategy policy
cs9 which seeks to protect neighbors
from overlooking overshadowing and
overbearing effects none of which will
occur with these proposals we have
submitted a section drawing that shows a
relative Heights and positions of the
garages in relation to the neighboring
properties this demonstrates the garages
comply with a 45 25 degree test that the
council uses to ensure a satisfactory
separation of buildings chairman this is
a sensitively designed scheme for
garages that complies with the policy
yes 9 which will provide security for
the vehicles secure parking for the
vehicles of the people who will occupy
this development I respectfully ask that
you support the offices recommendation
and grant planning permission thank you
German agent that's a bit of a long
story actually there's two completely
different answers to that one is of
course that under normal circumstances
these garages wouldn't need planning
permission because of their height what
we didn't anticipate was that you take
away all permitted development rights
and we have to apply for planning
permission that's a good indication that
normally the government national policy
considers garages of this sort of this
height won't affect neighbors therefore
they're permitted development so that's
the first reason they're taken out of
the scheme the second reason is business
continuity my client was on a site and
sell them he was looking to move to this
side he had people to employ people
employees we had to get a Planning
Commission to start building on this
side so we reduced the five dwellings
scheme down and I have to contradict I'm
afraid the previous speaker this is
nothing like the scheme that was refused
that was four five dwellings and garages
so we had to get a planning permission
for business continuities to keep people
employed so he had to take out
everything we could from the scheme to
get a planning permission my client is
perfectly entitled to make a succession
of applications and you consider each
one on his merits so we took it out to
secure the Planning Commission and as
you can see from the photographs it's
well underway it kept people employed
they're able to get on with the
development we've come back now to say
here we are reasonable proposals for
small domestic garages other questions
all right thank you mr. Bromley free to
go in Cova Ward member and substitute
committee member mr. kettle please
Thank You cancer kettle right Thank You
mr. chairman well why did this planning
committee remove permitted development
rights preventing development to all
additional garages as would normally be
the case which mr. Bromley is referred
to they did it for the specific reason
there's no want any further development
without it coming for this committee and
be considered properly so he's very good
mr. Bromley he's very persuasive but I
think we do need to consider actually
this cook this previous decision was
made for a purpose and that purpose is
exactly why we're here today
this committee did not want to have any
further development without proper
consideration the if you read on page 95
of your things you will see that both
the five application site 16 1 to 79 was
for a detached garage with home office
to do above not five detached garages so
there was never any application for five
garages on the site it's one so we just
get our facts correct we're now looking
to extrapolate one between five houses 2
3 4 3 but let's go back to the parish
councils comments which are really
relevant on page 1 page 93 of the
committee report description of site
constraints on stone hills special
landscape area immediately behind this
site that's above it on the picture you
can see on screen you've got the Burton
Hills a Country Park donated to Norwich
kind of council by the Smith family many
years ago used by hundreds of people
every year there are statistics of how
many people have been there but there
are very very significant visitors
outside and I've been there tobogganing
there very steep you look right down
over the village and this site which you
can see the Red Lodge sorry just is just
below
the Berkeley Hills development site so
doesn't just a matter of looking in from
top street it's a matter of looking in
from the hills as well but let's go in
part of the whole reason that this site
was considered to be over development
when five hazards went on it was because
there was a ring of building around the
entrance as you went into the house from
top Street that was removed by having
the spaces that were left by the fact we
only had one garage if we put these
garages in you effectively have a built
form with apart from the minor gaps
between the garage and reticle II we
don't get a horizontal view of the new
layout which we we were given a
horizontal view of this scheme but we're
not given one we've just shown the
independent garages Joe there wasn't one
that you put through and you were
shaking your head to confirm that
because what you'd actually have is
you'd walk into that site drive at that
site and you would have a solid line of
building all the way around now that is
not what this village currently looks
like it is in a special landscape area
and that the part of the reason we
remove Mitte development rights was to
continue to maintain that openness that
had previous been an orchard in a garden
to whatever the house is called the
grave Lodge in the corner so there are
many reasons why this site looks like it
is and coming back for a second bite of
the cherry which this committee sensibly
prohibited is it ignored those earlier
concerns as to why five wasn't good
enough for this committee three was but
three with lots of space around and then
I'd go on to the secured parking issue
one of the ecological comments and we
put forward is the importance of
providing nesting sites in the garages a
very good purpose of council dance would
he'd probably want nesting bricks as
well to allow birds to access these
garages if this is going to be secured
garetty then it's going to have to
garage doors that is not what we want
that is not what is described these are
open garages and I was going to ask for
a condition if the committee was
regrettably so minded as to support this
application was to insure these garages
left open at all times to enough to
allow nesting to continue as the county
ecologist has referred to so they won't
be secure garages because the ecologist
doesn't want them he wants them to be
open for nesting purposes of course that
doesn't make it very convenient with
people if they park their cars on it
birds make nests above because you have
a natural impact on cars which won't be
very pleasant but I think that is really
important to take into account the
ecologist is concerned about birds
these are concerned about a a walled
environment a compound let us consider
what that looks like
this is considered a special landscape
area let's consider why you remove
permitted developments last time Thank
You mr. chairman I think it says in the
report councillor who's recommended that
one garage is left open would you
confirm that's correct one gap that is
what he suggested my request is as
condition that all garages left opens
that they can provide more space rather
than having steel shutters coming down
which really does affect just to confirm
the recommendation was for one damage to
be left open that's correct
I'm asking for it to be conditioned
separately any further questions
Ketel you're free to go any points of
clarification no no okay we'll move on
to the debate so he wants to kick off
the debate now sir fielding I won't have
a look at this site yesterday and those
houses that are being developed are in
my book very out of keeping with the
surrounding properties they're tall but
I can't see in hindsight why garages
shouldn't resupplies and if you are
going to provide garages that need to be
open you can put nesting boxes on the
outside you can have swiss swift boxes
on the outside and also you can have
vents from our bats to fly in as we gave
planning permission elsewhere so I don't
see any problem really with these
garages can I still pouring thank you
chair obviously we've we've had the
chance to have a good look at the the
plans I can't see a planning reason to
refuse a like the fact that one of the
garages will be open I think
houses of this particular design need to
have a garage I think the fact that
they've got garages complements the
overall setting of this small scheme
which is just three three properties I'm
quite happy to propose the
recommendation that we go with the
officers recommendation to Brandt thank
you
just the clarification the recommended
conditions would need an additional
condition for one garage to remain open
so that would be an additional condition
if you if you were so minded I don't
think I don't think it's necessary to be
left open when we can have nesting boxes
I think it would be unfair to the other
occupants of the garages to who leaves
the damaged open so I'm happy with the
pros of what's in front of us it's got
18 conditions and three notes which I
think is acceptable probably to the
proposer and certainly to me as a second
I'm quite happy to go without it was
only picking up from the ecologists and
looking at the design thinking what was
was open but if we've got nesting boxes
to the side because they're detached
then that I'm quite happy to go with
that one of the conditions which would
be approved by the planning officer
fielding I agree with what's being said
I don't think I'd like to have my car
with a large deposit on it if I was to
park in one of those garages so I'll go
along with councillor Perry and marine
so we've got a professor in a second she
will go to vote all those in favor of
granting the application five chairmen
and any abstentions on chairman thank
you so committee resolves to grant
application 18 / 0 1 2 0 9 / very
I've rarely foot any urgent business
there's no urgent business so I know
declare the meeting closed